[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody thank you for joining
us thank you for hopping in
matt
what time is it over there man
it's uh one o'clock in the morning
west australian time
i really appreciate you staying up late
uh
with me
it's freaking awesome man it's 9 a.m
here in california
and it's 1am in perth
and we have come together to do this
stream for y'all it's going to be a very
chill stream i got to give a shout out
to my man adam feverkin who put that
custom music together for your awesome
visuals all that was from
your
various games your various
experiences that you've put together and
there's a link to your website in the
description down below where people can
hop in and play those games and explore
those environments do you want to tell
me a little bit about why
and how you got into making those things
matt
yeah so i guess um talk about what
you'll be downloading first it's
essentially like
like i make um
naturally inspired unreal engine
environments and i'm currently in the
process of putting together a video game
which is a compilation
of all the environments um
which you'll be able to download and
essentially a photography simulator so
you can walk around at your own pace
just like take a bunch of photos
um
and just sort of like absorbing the
atmosphere i guess yeah
it's such a cool idea man i love this
idea so much
it's like i feel we're so aligned
on just like
the atmospheric music and
the imagery man i love what you do so
much
it's so good and it's very unique like i
i've never really seen a video game like
this where you just kind of
walk around and take pictures you know
of course there's pokemon snap
but
this is very different and like there
are games like flow or or journey
and like those games are art pieces
um but there's definitely game elements
to it this is like very relaxing where
you walk around with a camera and take
really cool shots of
of the environment and you put these
environments together in such a cool way
i'm very excited to jump in with you and
like
figure out
how
we're going to make this how you make
these
so yeah i'm i'm so excited as well man
thanks everyone for having me by the way
like it's great to
be here i've never done a stream before
so it's awesome to see like everyone in
the chat
yeah this is great
yeah man it's gonna be a blast i'm i i
feel like
having guests on
is the way to do this
like
hanging out with someone who you admire
and creating art with them that's the
way to go and sharing off all their art
is so cool
um hunter i see you thank you for that
super chat much appreciated brother very
good stuff
um
yes it's good to be back it's good to be
back
yeah it's 1am where matt is it's 9 a.m
where i am
we are coming someone says i look tired
i'm not too bad honestly
i've been i've been preparing for this
so it's fine it's all good
yeah so hey what are we gonna do today
what are we what are we gonna do
what's the goal um
i had this idea um
i've been watching a bunch of youtube
videos from
a youtuber called craig adams recently
and the styles of videos that he does he
does like
like silent hiking films that's a way to
describe it he does like long like 15
minute
compilations of an entire hike where
the video is essentially just footage of
him walking with the sounds of like his
footsteps and nature
hey
i can switch over to your display if
you're ready oh yeah yeah i can get up
the video yeah
it's on younow so yeah
cool um
so i'll just place in the background i
suppose
so he just does like
atmospheric like shots of him walking
through like amazing landscapes um
i personally have relied on his videos a
lot to like put in the background while
i'm working i find it's like a great
uh a great thing to have i'm watching
inspiration
um yeah so he just like captures all the
great details and i thought that this
would just make like an awesome um
an awesome like base for like a project
like some of these environments have
like such great detail um and there's
one part in the video
like a couple minutes ago
like this awesome like red sun coming
through i really i saw that scene i was
like yeah i'd love to make it out of
that so
beautiful
yeah we'll we'll see what we can achieve
on this on this stream um
hopefully it's not too ambitious i've
only got like a few hours but now
yeah i'm so excited yeah so basically
we're going to create a small
environment very much like matt has
created for his games
but these are obviously to a much larger
scale we're going to
break down we're gonna boil down uh your
skill matt and we're gonna apply it to
a very small scene that you're gonna
help guide me through
um
and the audience as well unreal engine
is free
and
y'all can hop in and learn with us for
free if you have unreal engine
um
i think we're in version 4.27 we're
going to be in here
and we want by the end of this stream we
want to have a downloadable exe file
that you can play and hop into and like
explore this environment that we're
going to create right now
for yourself
so
that's pretty sweet that's the goal yeah
that's the goal obviously yeah with
australian internet i don't know how far
we'll get with like uploading the build
and everything but
aim is to have yeah playable exe file
downloadable you can like walk around
uh just look at everything yeah
we'll see we'll see how we get
sweet sweet um i just saw i just saw
will for sure in the chat
yeah what's up great to see you man i
love i love his tutorials i've learned
so much from you man
yeah he is he's the one
he's freaking so great so nice um
he was on last month we did a live
stream together
and
that dude is that dude is the best
yeah i watched three i watched through
that was great
um shout outs to my boy devon williams
holding it down in joja
good to see you dude well i'm not seeing
you but it's night i sense your presence
that's that's the important thing
um
so
where do we begin man let's
let's switch over here let's open up
unreal engine
uh yeah i can
i can tell people a bit about who i am i
guess
people have no idea
yeah well yeah here let's i'm getting
ahead of myself thanks for thanks for
hitting the brakes on that
who are you just cause what are you
doing i don't i don't upload youtube
videos like i'm not yeah i wondered
like who is this guy
um
yeah so
i um yeah i'm from i'm from perth west
australia i am currently still an
engineering student regretfully i really
wish i could by now
um but i picked up unreal while i was
studying uh and that sort of stemmed
from
me doing a bunch of photography back
when i was in high school and that
continued i used to love taking photos
while i was traveling
um i sort of built up a knowledge of
like color correction and like i did a
little bit of videography but not too
much
and i was at a point where
i really felt
uh yeah like i could dive into something
that can stick my teeth into you know
like photography is great and all but um
but i really felt like there was more i
could do i wanted to like move
uh move the mountains move the sun and
have more
like customizability about what i was
creating so
so this was about um about three years
ago it was the beginning of 2018 i do
started diving into unreal and um
and yeah since then i've just been like
just it's a matter of like googling
every single problem you have on the
unreal answer hub that's how you get
there
yeah it's a lot of trouble shooting
the constant troubleshooting absolutely
it's it's a huge program there's so much
there's so much stuff man it blows me
away um
yeah so i just yeah i began to make
scenes that were inspired by you know
the places i've been the photos i've
taken um
i always found that photos are the best
like point of reference you're making a
photo realistic
environment it's great to like look at
the way light interacts with things and
um and as well as realism you also want
to put like your own flair on things you
know like with
colors and
atmosphere so
yeah that's that's sort of how i i got
to hear um
unreal sort of has a lot of facets in
like lots of industries um i've been
very lucky to be
uh in this spot as lots of people have
sort of converged on on unreal
yeah um
because yeah there are so many there's
so many applications for it like it
started out as a game engine and it's
really fleshed out in those aspects
um but yeah like i figured you know has
a lot of what i needed um and then
through that through making environments
i've been able to like
to work in like bits of films i've done
like live visuals and on a little bit of
game development
yeah all sorts of stuff i think it's
really cool that
you
are a photographer
first and
you base a lot of your 3d art on the
places you've been
um i don't really know
of anyone else who does
that kind of thing because that's
i love traveling i think we're both very
similar and that we love to travel and
we both love japan very much
and going to these places where you
don't feel like you actually feel like
you're exploring a new place
that's why traveling is the best you
meet new people you discover new places
and you get lost in a place that you've
never been before and sometimes when you
go out
into the mountains into nature
without your phone
and you have a camera and you have some
ambient music and you're out there just
enjoying
nature
that's so inspiring it's so inspiring
and it's funny because like we have this
instinct to
capture that
bring it back to our house and be like
man i just want to be in that as much as
possible let's create an environment
based off of where i was
it's so funny but like it gets me so
excited
it's the best
yeah i mean even even back from like i
used to watch corridor quite a lot and i
like immediately recognize that from
your work like you put out some amazing
renders like oh thanks man i
automatically like connected with that i
particularly loved like i loved the the
render you did in the car next to the
docks that's my favorite one of yours i
appreciate it man that was yes that was
based off a trip that i took with adam
the feverkin the guy who did the music
at the intro here who you know of um
it's cool that we all all three of us
are connected in like one spot now on
the stream
that's that's awesome
um but yeah it was a trip with adam
and like i've never been to such an
intense place
before um
and i just wanted to capture that as
as much as po i want to like distill it
down to
a video you know an experience
so it's amazing man like when i saw that
i was like oh clint has like the perfect
idea of like what i'm about
heck yeah dude that's amazing um
i'm really i'm really amped to to dive
in with you and like see what we can
create i feel like we could just do this
for hours and hours and hours and hours
and that's true listen yeah there are
always tons of details to
look at
um before we hop in maybe clock's
ticking maybe we should get started oh
yeah go ahead yeah yeah we should get
started i just want to give a shout out
to one dead duck for the super chat
i really appreciate you
um
everybody here everybody who's hopping
in i know i've been streaming less these
days to take some time for myself and
it's been great it's been fantastic so i
really appreciate everyone who's hopping
in here and learning with us today so
let's do it
let's hop in shall we
yeah let's do it all right yeah thanks
to shannon hunter
shea
linda boulder
yeah good to see everyone sorry i just
love i just love having like a live
reaction all this is awesome oh you
don't have to apologize for that dude
absolutely
people are holding it down yeah okay so
um do you want to describe to us what
we're in here like what what's going on
in this scene can anyone get this scene
or is this like uh
what what's going on here
so i just set up like a template project
for us to work with i
i was tempted to go from nothing but
obviously um
time is against us i just thought like
it's great to put in some trees and
whatnot because we'll be relying on mega
scans for a lot of stuff we include but
uh mega stands doesn't have any trees at
this live stream which i think it's
actually planned or i've heard rumors or
announced some sort of announcement the
trees might be in mega scans at some
point in the future but
uh until then yeah it'll be us like
we'll be importing a whole bunch of
surface textures for the landscape we'll
be importing
a lot of a lot of meshes that we can lay
out over the ground and when we import
these meshes we'll be using a bunch of
our
custom-made master materials that i've
already imported into the project so
my project's looking a bit more
complicated than clint's maybe but
that's because i imported the first
person blueprint that i'm working with
this first person blueprint is like
um essentially the the game format that
i use for my my project so you have like
a camera that you can use and walk
around with so
i included this because at the very end
of the game i'll be able to
just put that in the scene and then
hopefully click compile and then we'll
have an exp that's playable
um so i thought it was best that i
figured that stuff out beforehand smart
yeah
but yeah aside from that so
where to jump in um i've got a list that
we can start off with so i was just
gonna like make a start on the landscape
um i'm gonna be importing some materials
from
mega scans
so just
jose thank you
for the super chat
appreciate you very much thanks for
hanging out with us
so you're building what's your plan here
you you said you want to go and create
that like sunset
uh tree
scene from the video yeah
that's the goal so yeah i watched a
bunch of the scenes from the video and i
tried to like gauge what the ground
looks like what kinds of like
assets will use to put this together um
i had browsed mega scans for a while
just like searching some key terms that
i thought would
help like you know mossy rocks and um
those surfaces so
uh i'm gonna show my screen stream right
now but we got um yeah you're on yeah
just some cool we got some like
varied surfaces i picked like a couple
different types of snow and
brown textures um
yeah i think i'll be starting with
uh yeah these surface textures here
which i which i won't use um
the mega scans plugin for i'll just
import those manually
uh just because the mega scans plugin
creates materials automatically but we
actually have
a master material that i've made that i
want to use
so
i guess clean if you're following along
we can
go to like a masters folder
all right let's see here
okay in landscape maskers we'll want to
create a material instance from the
landscape template master material got
you so that's a right click right at the
top create material instance suite
and i'm going to go into my
folder that's saved on my computer and
just like drag those textures in
into where
so just into the content browser oh got
you i've never done it this way actually
really
yeah i've never done it this way that's
good good for now
we're going to want our albedo our
displacement and our normal maps
oh i see you're talking about the actual
textures
the image the images yeah so in in mega
scans there's like a function you can
click go to files and it opens up the
file location for you perfect
so this is for your ground plane right
we're building up a ground plane
essentially yeah so the way landscape
materials work is you can choose a
couple of different surfaces that you
like to blend between
because i've imported my landscape mask
material already
most of the hard work's been done for us
we can just
import our textures into the project and
then get those into our material
instance that we've made
i guess to show off the
landscape template that i've made
which is here
goodness um we've got like a
i mean it looks clear to me but i guess
that's because i'm because i've built it
yeah what's the simplest form of this it
looks like you have a few duplicated
things right
yeah so all of these are
different material instances and they
all blend using this node which is going
to be a height blend so
we'll be referencing all the albedos and
normal maps here
and then in the middle we've just got a
bunch of like parameters we can adjust
things like brightness color tint
desaturation
they all come into this node here yeah
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure exactly
how much material design you've done
with but um i guess i'll just yeah i'll
just try and stay as clear as possible
with what i've done here in notebooks so
you're basically combining a number of
materials
on
the left right if you can go back to
that
to that material view
um
so you're combining a bunch together
into that like middle node right what is
that node in the middle that they're all
going into what is that what's called
the
layer blends layer blend got you okay
and then all right what's going on on
the right
and here we've just got um i guess these
are sort of like hacky kind of
workarounds that i've done so i've sort
of split the material attributes here
which is
just means i can do sort of last minute
modifications like here i've got like a
texture overlay which helps like the
vary the brightness
in the distance um
and then down here we've got a um
we've got contact shadows we've got
material contact shadows these are
actually really
really cool i'd love to talk
about these a little bit more
a bit later
but um
you should be able to
you should be able to open the same
material
on your end right
yeah i i yeah i just need to choose what
material i want for the ground um
cool and yeah um
but i guess because yeah i i favorited
my material so i know what i'm
putting in already that's good that's
good do you want to maybe like
link those up while i
figure out what ground plane i'm going
to use
yeah sounds good i mean i'm i'm
interested to see like i'm sort of happy
that you'll be choosing a bunch of
different services and assets so we'll
see like
it might be yeah it'll be interesting
what you come up with
yeah i might try and go for like a snowy
scene
to have something a little different um
but yeah i remember we were looking at
we're looking at that one shot um
like with craig walking through like
some foggy sections i cannot be sweet
yeah yeah agreed
um and hey william i really appreciate
you answering questions here in the chat
that's really nice of you man um
one of the questions here hunter was
asking is there a way to collaborate in
unreal engine um and and william
mentioned
uh omniverse which is a possibility
uh but hunter's basically asking like
are we working on
the same file or two separate files um
this is two separate files right now but
yeah how would how would you collaborate
on one file in unreal engine
i've out of experience i've only worked
on my own projects i haven't i haven't
worked collaboratively on a game or
anything like that um but
but i'm aware that um you know
collaboration is the whole thing there's
like version control and everything
implemented through like
through github you can you can set up
the project and people can download
branches and everything
uh yeah it's a whole thing
i just haven't i just haven't delved in
too far into it yeah
same
but it'd be nice for these streams
actually it'd be pretty sweet to like
do some collaborative that's true
yeah thinking about it now like if
you're working on a similar project in
the future
yeah you really work really well
um also shout outs to khalifa for the
super chat much appreciated thanks for
hanging out with us and chillin
um and and william again i really
appreciate you answering those questions
in the chat man that's super super nice
of you very very cool
um
it's quite a treat to have you in there
as well man
so okay i need to figure out what the
heck i'm gonna do like what what
i need to figure out what my ground
plane's going to be i'm going to start
downloading a bunch of snow assets and
bringing those in
um if you want to start downloading your
ground and like maybe once you get
things set up we can talk about
how they're set up is that does that
sound good
yeah no problem i'm just um chugging in
a couple of textures
right now
okay sounds good
yeah i guess once i've got things set up
i'll i'll walk you through it so
um
oh we got casey up in here
snap casey edwards
very talented composer
he is the go-to he is the
man composer casey what's going on
we used to live together
but saying we used to live together
sounds like it was so long ago i feel
like it's only like a year ago
what up casey good to see you dude
oh man boards of canada ah i wish you
have to put that on yourself
i wish i could do that right now i do
want to figure out a way to like add
music to these streams
because it would elevate the vibe the
right music would elevate the vibe no
doubt
all right i'm just downloading excuse me
for not
yeah good forgive me for not um looking
at the chat too much i
i'm really
concentrating on this deadline i really
want to
get something together let's do it yeah
but i guess i also yeah i also don't
want to like
go blazingly fast or everything so no
one can
pick up on anything that i did so now
we'll we'll go back and we'll touch on
things that need to be touched on
yeah cool cool if there's anything like
like glaze over or there was a chat
question that um highlighted something
please please let me know
sounds good
well i gotta update my plugins
i'm ready for i guess i can explain what
i'm doing i'm ready for like my next
step i'm importing my textures um
yeah before
i um
yeah like so i've got my landscape
um material instance here so i'm just
gonna
where i've got it set up is that each
each texture is like a parameter so i
can just like feed in
what i've got i've chosen a variation
i've chosen
two snow textures um one ground texture
and one leaves texture
i actually might have forgotten these
section
so your master material
you're saying that this instance
which we're using to populate to a bunch
of different pieces of geometry
you wouldn't drop the instance on things
so
yeah the reason we use an instance is
just so we can
like manipulate the different
parameters of the material on the fly
like if you want to adjust like
brightness color anything to do with
that
uh if you have an instance the the
effect will be immediate on the
landscape uh instead of having to like
you just did it within the material
you'd have to like compile and wait for
it to compile yeah and that's very it's
like very different because
in cinema 4d or blender like
you don't really do that and i was like
why would i need to create two of the
same material here this doesn't make any
sense
but yeah basically you have a master
material which is
the full material built out and then you
have the instance which is the one that
is easily duplicated throughout all the
different geometry in your scene
so it just keeps things running a lot
faster
yeah pretty much um like i
like i don't actually have any i don't
have much experience with other
renderers like unreal is sort of the
only thing that i know so
um
that's awesome i have to like at some
point at some point i'll have to dive
into like another render and see how
everything is handled it's that
curiosity
um like i was meaning to pick
more seriously but
i think blender and unreal engine is a
great combination together like oh
absolutely they're both free
right and like
you can't really model in
unreal engine like unreal engine to me
at least for my purposes i'm using it to
bring assets together
and
uh
to build out environments in real time
and of course you can like gamify it you
know which is what you have done
uh you turn it into a video game for me
i'm i'm here for like the photo real
uh real-time
environments for
storytelling um and for
you know for like narrative scenes
essentially
for vfx
um
but it has so many uses and that's why
this program is so darn confusing at
times it's because
it was originally made for games but
people are using like now it's it's kind
of starting to be marketed as like oh
you can actually do this for vfx and
like production too
and there's so many
layers to this program
that
i don't use because i'm not making games
but you but matt you are tapped in to
the game side of things as well as
william too you know william william was
in that as well but both of you guys are
like
very attuned to this entire program and
this is this is your jam so i'm i'm very
excited to be learning from you and be
doing this with you man this is super
cool
i'm such a new thanks man yeah i guess
william like
william like he um he sounds like much
more of a veteran like he said he was
around like during the
unreal engine three days like the source
development kit and stuff like that like
i've gone through a couple of forums but
like that's about it like he he
definitely knows
much more in that sense um
but you know like
um i i've been thinking about it a bit
like which would
would it be a good thing for unreal to
split into like a cinematic renderer and
and a game development tool
and it's an interesting it's an
interesting um
conversation but i think like the more
i've thought about it i actually
rely on a lot of game tools for the um
or the rendering stuff that i do like
through through the game development
integration i can like do
so many complicated things that would
have taken me ages to do in a
traditional renderer like
i i put out a scene recently which is
essentially um
like
it's a bit hard to explain but all the
instances on the landscape sort of like
fly up into the air sort of
um harmoniously
yeah let me let me pull that up real
quick let me let me oh i can do that you
want to let me think
uh
really hard for a second
where is that
um
here we go
it's funny this video is adam sent this
to me
and he's and this is titled
cave's reel for punisher bro
oh yeah i saw that
okay here we go let me switch over so
yeah this like exploded out view
i i was wondering how the heck did you
do this
yeah like i was gonna say like so
traditionally that kind of stuff would
take i mean i would assume it would take
like key frames animations and things
like that
you have to keep framing a lot of stuff
um
but uh yeah considering it's a game
development engine you can just have a
material that references a single value
and then make that value unanimous among
all instances so the value would be
respective of okay here's the center
point
and how far away from the center point
is this instance so you have that and
then you'd essentially have just like a
sweeping effect from from zero to one
and then it would just bring in like
it would make all of the assets sweep up
into the air
um
and so yeah i was quite i was quite
happy with that one when i put that
together because um yeah dude it's
awesome
obviously the scene took quite a long
time to make and so just putting just
doing like a quick render with like a
cool effect i don't know it's lots of
fun it's really good well it really like
lets you see one how many things are
going into this how many little assets
and how many pieces
are either hand placed or
actually that's a great question do you
hand place all your stuff like how much
of it is scattered around uh
randomly well not randomly but like
you know
autumn automatically scattered versus
hand placed
when i first started i definitely like
did a whole bunch of individual
instancing like using the foliage tool
just like placing things here and there
yeah and yeah that was super time
consuming so
yeah more recently like the last few
years i've been delving into like
procedural foliage tools and things like
that
yeah which which can be really useful um
i've sort of found that the best
the best outcome is to have like a
combination of the two where you're
like starting with instead of starting
with a blank slate you start with a
completely procedurally generated like
forest for example
and then instead of so instead of
building from nothing you're like
starting with a forest and then building
back on things that you don't like and
then adding detail to parts where you
need it
i found that that's so much faster than
yeah placing instances from scratch and
like
doing all of that like what we're do
what we're doing right now essentially
kind of yeah i'm still sorry i'm going
so slowly by the way um i it's okay i'm
just putting my
it's like no i have no like ability to
like work until
here why don't you why don't you get it
i'll take over i'll
i'll uh
i'll talk them through my process here
which is
just me grabbing assets and bringing
them in which
was really difficult to figure out
at
like the very beginning of things
so basically
you download unreal engine okay you're
like how do i even download unreal
engine that's the first thing i asked
and you and then you got to get the like
epic games launcher it's like no i want
to download unreal engine
but that's how you do it you got to
download the epic games launcher and in
the epic games launcher
you know it brings up
this whole thing right here and
basically
you're going to hit this unreal engine
tab on the left and you're going to go
to
library and you're going to download
different versions
of
the program
and we're in 427 right now people are
all hyped up on unreal 5.
um
so
that's how you launch it and you jump in
and then you're presented with the
program you're like okay well
how do i make stuff look good where do i
go from there well
getting the mega scans plug-in is
probably uh
the next thing you want to do this comes
pre-installed in unreal five and you can
browse the marketplace
for all of these free assets it's like
it's ridiculous how all this stuff is
free
it's not fair
like it it's ridiculous um i'm gonna
just download
this real quick because that looks cool
um
but i believe
boy it's been a minute
since i've done this but once you
download bridge you're essentially going
to
manage plugins perhaps you want to make
sure that you have your unreal engine
plug-in installed here and when you
export things there's a little cog on
the bottom right which you all can
barely see
you got download and export settings and
you want to make sure it's going to
unreal engine
make sure the plugins downloaded and it
might need to be enabled here um
by going to settings
plugins perhaps and if i search for mega
scans
it is enabled yeah and you'll need to
restart and then
what you can do is start
downloading stuff
and exporting you'll see in the top
right
export successful
and back in unreal you're gonna get a
little load bar
and it's gonna just work its way over
across the internet all the way into
your scene this doesn't matter
and
snowy embankment let's see
bam here we go
right and then you have your scene which
you drop in
and i'm navigating through this program
by holding right click and using wasd
just like you're playing a first person
shooter or something
and orbiting around the scene and
spacebar actually cycles between
the different navigational tools so i'm
just hitting spacebar to move this stuff
around i don't know what i'm going to
build yet i don't know
what scene i'm going to i mean obviously
i'm doing a snowy scene here i just
don't know my composition i don't know
the layout of my stuff i think what i'm
doing right now is just
gathering assets i'm gathering as many
assets that i'm going to use to build
out my scenes essentially my legos i'm
getting all my lego pieces ready
everything is laid out in the world
outliner so if i were to clean this up
i can select all my geometry and in the
top right here this little folder we can
click that and just type
geometry
boom
and i like to make another one for light
so i have my skylight
and
let's see
exponential height fog directional light
i'm just going to put that in a folder
called
light
and this blank template here this was
actually matt sent this over to me so
that we can be sped up and working
quickly on the stream but when you hop
in you might start with a blank template
you'll be
you'll be uh what's the word um
you'll have a menu and in that menu
you're going to see like do i want to
start with a blank template do i want to
start with uh
you know a first person shooter template
and you can choose between game or
television and production right and you
essentially each one of those templates
toggles certain plugins on and off
for what you're specifically using it
for so i'm i usually go with the like
film and tv template you can do a blank
one or
time of day template
just to get you
a sun and uh
some atmosphere and whatnot in your
scene already
so i'm just dropping stuff in here
and trying to build out my lego pieces
yeah how's how's everything going
you need to give your hand with your
landscape
um
i don't want to save kids just at the
perfect moment
every time i'm i'm just down though i'm
like gathering assets right now so i'm
still
i'm honestly kind of like
trying to avoid
the material setup maybe we should i
should just rip off that band-aid and
like
jump in with it um
i'm like oh shoot that looks advanced
but let me download a couple more of
these embankments
um how are you feeling you feeling like
you can talk about some stuff right now
or uh
yeah i i wanted to mention
yeah i wanted to mention like with the
whole design of the scene um
like usually you would make a
composition with your with your
environment and like frame everything up
nicely get everything looking perfect um
but with what i wanted to make on the
stream i guess you'd sort of take a
different approach like this is how i
usually approach my my landscape because
i just make a huge
sort of half randomly generated
environment with
a lot of like
sporadic placements for trees like twigs
everything
and then
the final render sort of come from you
know like random angles that i found in
the environment so
once you put a whole bunch of random
stuff together i found
sort of in the same
the same vein of real world videography
and photography you have an environment
that exists already and you just go
around and like find angles
and obviously
for some
for some projects like that's not the
right way to go about things obviously
you need like a really specific look
specific composition
um but i found that you know in some
aspects it really does help like if you
if you make a composition from something
that's randomly somewhat randomly
generated
it just creates a lot of like nice
i don't know how to say it like like
opportunities to discover
um interesting angles on the fly
right
yeah it's sort of like something that's
more naturally inspired i suppose like
if you're taking shows in the landscape
uh trees are never placed perfectly
anywhere like
like people who do landscape nature
photography have to like make their own
angles and nothing is ever placed
completely perfectly
um
that's a great thing yeah that's a
really great point and you know like it
reminds me of
the
that cabin breakdown that blender guru
made you remember that one
i think i saw a bit of that yeah yeah um
is such a great video you all should
check it out blender guru he walks you
through like 20 to 25 minutes the
creation of his cabin uh piece of art
and
he talks about like i've never heard
this before and you just described it
very similar to how he did and basically
what he says is like he places his cabin
he scatters his trees and then he like
randomizes the camera's position
and its focal length
i think and the sun position
and every frame is a new
position for all of those things
and he hits go and it just makes like
thousands of them overnight and when he
wakes up in the morning he can toggle
through
each one and like
pick the ones that look the coolest so
it's like a it's a it's like a random
seed but for your lighting your camera
angle and your focal length so it's a
great way to generate ideas very quickly
and i've never done that before but
it that's actually a great idea for like
what you're describing about randomly
generating your environment and then
trying to find the cool angles within
that and then of course hyping those up
and building those out
once you find something cool you know
yeah absolutely i totally agree like
it's just yeah with with maybe for
people who've only ever done like
structured um scenes and structured
compositions so it's like it really
helps like i know with inspiration and
i guess it's sort of real relatable in
some ways like you know like i don't
know if everyone's seen like bob ross
but
you know you have like happy accidents
and like mistakes those are all good
like
i've sort of found that that that sort
of imperfection like helps a lot with
trying to make something
yeah because it's like it makes sense
because
it's a random discovery that works
and
it's almost like a gift from heaven that
comes down it's like oh snap i wouldn't
have been able to do this with my brain
but i recognize with my brain that it's
cool so i should probably roll with that
um
you know they say they say the same
thing when you're when you're shooting a
movie like
you're gonna plan things out as much as
possible when you're making a movie
you're gonna have a storyboard you're
gonna have a script you're gonna have
like pre-visualizations for fight scenes
you're gonna have everything pre picked
out you're gonna have rehearsals the
actors know they're gonna
do it a certain way
but when you get there on the day
and randomness
you know hops into the mix which it
always does
that can be chaotic and stressful but
i think to a great filmmaker or a great
artist that random chaos can be
harnessed
and if you're aware of
the greatness that comes from that and
you can harness it it's it's gonna like
add a level of like magic to your art
and
it's so rare that i get that in 3d
because everything is just
hand placed and hand done but the way
you describe that man that
that's really cool
i'm glad that that element can be
brought to
this process
yeah it's good to hear i mean that's
sort of just the way i've always done
things and i know in a lot of cases it's
not the best way but yeah
like how i like to do things i guess
that's great um did you by the way did
you need your help how are you going
i'm chilling i'm just uh
you know downloading
assets and like
okay um i think i will need help when we
get to like the material side of things
but yeah what do you suggest okay if we
want to do this random generated
version of like what you're talking
about how would
how would we go about doing that right
now what do i need to do to to get that
going
so
uh if we had more time i would suggest
using procedural foliage volumes which
involve you know you've got a lot of
foliage
assets and you place them all into the
volume and then you have to set all
these parameters and get everything
uh neat so it has like these clusters
and all this complicated stuff but for
today i think um
once we've got a landscape that looks
looks decent i think we'll chuck a bunch
of um foliage into the
foliage painter and then just
sort of um
am i randomly you know like place
classes of trees here and there i think
that's the best way to do things it's
often
for me it's like i like to do things a
bit more quickly than spending hours
like
arranging procedural foliage volumes um
got you okay so maybe the randomness
style isn't the best way to go for this
stream right now because we're on a
limited time
i mean it's still it's still somewhat
random like we're still going to import
like a height map for the landscape
hopefully and um and then when we when
we paint we're just going to paint with
like a huge brush so we set like the
density of trees and then we just paint
over a section we'll get like an even
distribution of the trees cool
so yeah there'll still be like a random
element to it for sure all right sounds
good sounds good what am i missing it
looks like you got
it looks like you've got a bunch of
stuff i i think i'll help you get your
landscape set up properly um sweet so
we've got pretty much the same setup
right now like we've both got a bunch of
assets that we've we've dragged in uh
you've got some nice snow fascists which
looks great
um i yeah i've set up my landscape
material so that i've i've been able to
paint a couple of surfaces on the ground
um
so where are you at with that have you
made a material instance
yeah i've made the material instance but
i don't have any materials plugged in so
maybe i should find a couple uh a couple
materials to
drop into that instance i would assume
that's probably the way to go yeah
yeah yeah so if you if you found any
surface materials that you want to use
for mega scans
you can either i guess i i've dragged in
the textures manually but you're welcome
to like
import them and then you can still use
the same
texture
yeah let me um
okay so i'm gonna download a couple
a couple materials here
a couple snowy materials
um and then we're going to manually drag
them in
and drop them into your custom instance
is that correct
yeah essentially yeah um
i'll have to tell you how to
set everything up but um at the moment
uh so i had to
create the instance
put in all the textures in their
respective slots and then after that um
you'll have to open up the
landscape painter
mode and then
you'll have to make
uh
landscape layer files so
uh it's not very complicated you just
have to click like
when you
create a new layer you just click create
weight blended layout
and that's essentially it okay all right
we'll get there
um
let's see i should download a
a variety
of snow textures
i'm assuming right yeah so the maximum
is
for the material i've designed is for
textures um
and i
i usually like to include yeah just a
bit of variance like you don't
necessarily have to use all the textures
i guess if you just got like one
significant like snow texture and one
maybe rock texture and that's what
you're going with i think that should be
fine
all right sounds good
sounds great
all right i'm almost done here so i need
to navigate to the files actually on my
computer
and
i think you can you can just import them
it does create material instances but
you can't use those as long as yeah i
think exporting uh using the plugin
should be fine because it imports the
textures as well yeah all right let me
do this then let's do
right we're chilling in here let's bring
in this like
snow trampled material
let's grab this wind swept
snowy stones material and
there's like a fresh
windswept snow
i think any one of these will be fine
grab that
okay all right and those all because we
got our mega scans plugins set up those
are all coming up into our scene
right now
so i have three
which i think will be fine i guess for
this
um i might explain about um something i
really love in landscape materials which
is the contact shadows um
[Music]
so regretfully um before the stream i
couldn't i didn't really have the time
but i would have loved to include like
height maps with um with each of the
textures so
what i'm doing right now is i'm
just like putting in new texture samples
to sample a
displacement texture just to
sort of demonstrate this effect but
um well question first
do you have a visual example of what
you're talking about at this right now
not right now i'd have to i have to get
that set up first um but so contact
shadows are
essentially just like really detailed
shadows uh when you have your lighting
in unreal the default it comes from a
directional light it's cascade shadows
and they look great and they respond to
moving objects and everything which is
awesome um but if you like zoom in
really close to like the edge of a
an object in the scene there's not
really any detail there you have to like
really bump up the um
the
trace
i think oh not the trace count but um
yeah you have to step up the quality
which is like a huge performance hit um
so you're talking about this
between the tree and the ground there's
just like a nasty hard line
that seam right there right
yeah so the shadow sort of like sort of
cuts off halfway if i just enable
contact shadows real quickly really
quick you'll know what i'm talking about
so
you sort of see like the the detail
doesn't extend very far because contact
shadows only sample like two objects
that are really short distance away from
each other okay
but around objects like maybe i'll find
something for example so if i have
something that's um
with half blending in and out of the
landscape this isn't perfectly blended
just yet but
are you'll sort of see just like much
more detailed shadows come from the
object as opposed to if i turn off
contact shadows
then they disappear so
got you okay yeah that's that's what
contact shows are and contact shadows in
general i suppose it's worth mentioning
like i when i design my scenes i design
with optimization
like considering i want to use these
environments in real time
it's not always a choice that you need
to make if you're just exporting some
renders like some nice um
ray trace lighting but
uh yeah these all of these all these
tricks and things i'll be i'll be
showing will mostly be with the mindset
of like creating an optimized
environment
so what you're saying is that contact
shadow that looks realistic
if you were to have that on literally
every single
piece of geometry that you're scattering
across your scene it would
your frame rate would drop
considerably and you wouldn't be able to
have like a 60 fps experience in your
game
so
so what i'm saying is contact shadows
are essentially like a technique you
would only use for
for games because they're because it's
very efficient like you can essentially
have contact shadows over the entire
scene as many as you want for free
because it's a screen space effect like
it's very cheap
gotcha so
what i'm saying is like
if you were to do this with ray tracing
you'll have to like
pop the settings a lot um
or just like have uh
have that kind of outlook over the scene
in general but contact shadow is just
sort of like a trick if that makes sense
like
a trick that helps like get some nice
details in where there are like small
changes in the geometry
obviously when you get larger distances
or you get really close to it it sort of
like dissolves like you can see here but
um
yeah it's very much like a uh an
optimization trick to get some really
nice uh
really nice details sweet once i get
these
uh contact coats up within the material
so within the landscape material it's um
essentially yeah it's the same thing but
it's embedded into the material so even
if you don't have any geometric detail
in the material and no displacement and
no bumps or anything
um
if you have contact shutters turned on
and you have uh this this bunch of
arithmetic here enabled
it will allow for like some shadows to
come in on the landscape um
yeah it's just sort of like a neat trick
hopefully i'll be able to get something
that's uh
presentable
yeah sounds good i think right now i i
need to catch up to where you're at as
far as uh
well
let's see do we want to scatter some
stuff around and start to build a scene
and then once we have something uh
let me let me ask you this do you want
to do you want to do the contact shadow
thing now do you want to set that up now
or do you want to start building a scene
what would you prefer
i i usually leave scene building to like
near almost near the end okay cool cool
yeah i think i'll do my contact shadows
while you're while you're still working
if you're slightly behind have you got
the landscape
set up i i have my materials downloaded
but i don't have anything dropped into
that instance i don't have any like
yeah i don't have that stuff set up
okay cool so
um
i guess i can i'll talk you through it
just so we can
progress at the same same rate yeah
um let me know once you've got the
the landscape material instance up
okay
um just want to quickly shout out a
couple people one day duck i appreciate
you for that super chat there yes i can
export multiple items at once from
quicksilver thank you
good stuff um
what else alex thank you for the super
chat as well i love a good snowy
embankment as well that's why i'm
putting that one together um
i'm very excited about this so we're
gonna get this ground plane going and
get our you know i've never done this
before so
i'm i am at your whim here so we got uh
in the masters
folder under what was it material
functions
nope
uh yep so content masters and landscape
masters is where i put the
materials got it okay so i'm in the
instance
right now
cool so if you scroll down to
global texture parameter values you'll
see yeah a bunch like normal one normal
two
yeah
yeah that's where you put in all of your
textures so if you decide which ones
you're going to allocate to be like
number one number two yeah uh you would
slot in
the albedo into the albedo
slot and then you
spot the corresponding normal map to the
normal got you so um it's just normal
and albedo that's all we really need
yeah that's all we're dealing with a lot
of materials go into like specular maps
all sorts of stuff i
this material specifically
i've decided to reference the albedo as
a specular map
just to sort of save performance that's
how i'd like to approach it
um because i figured with a lot of
albedo you can actually draw some
specular detail like depending on the
surface obviously but
um for a lot of my purposes i found that
representing the albedo for specular
works
pretty well it's um
it's what i like to go with
all right so i got everything in here
cool
um and then i love to include my
displacement maps obviously my
preference is not to include that as a
separate
texture parameter
my
my choice is often to
embed the displacement map into the into
the albedo with photoshop you can like
modify the alpha channel so that it
displays the displacement map
so in the material you just reference
the colors and then from the alpha you
reference the displacement and i found
that that's a great
performance saver i don't know if
that'll make sense to many people but i
just want to put it out there
it it's it's it's a high level tip that
half makes sense to me and i think
if
if um
i don't know if we get to a point where
you can show the difference between like
at the end show the difference between
what it looks like with or without
um
but
i think the p for the people that that
makes sense to i'm sure they're like
heck yeah
absolutely i'm i'm such a like i said
i'm such a noob and i'm like trying to
follow here um so i really i really
appreciate your patience with me as
we're uh no no as we're creating this
together
and uh evolver what's up
good to see you welcome back thank you
for the super chat
thanks for the support and thanks for
everyone just hanging out with us and uh
and chilling we got a steady steady
viewer group here i appreciate you all
um yeah sort of sort of apologize for
like really concentrating on the project
i'm like maybe maybe i'm pushing this
too hard like i really want to get
something out at the end of the two
hours but
i've been meaning to read through the
chat for a bit we'll be good we'll be
good
so i got this
like
material instance set up
what's the next step how do i how do i
like visualize this how do i use this
okay cool so
if you have your landscape selected in
the details panel you'll be able to
insert your
landscape material instance
where it says landscape material
got it okay so it's just darkness
so yeah that's
that should mean it's working great
so
i think i'm bringing you a screen now
uh actually it's probably a bit delayed
but um so once you've got that set up um
you want to go into landscape painting
mode by pressing shift three
shift two sorry shift two
and then you'll see a bunch of slots um
for each of them you have to press the
plus icon which says create layer info
and then you will want to save a
weight blended layer
all right i'm switching over to you i
guess
okay cool
so in
target layers in the height map area or
because i'm trying to find out where
that is
so if you're in landscape painting mode
it should be just in the landscape tab
got you yeah i'm in the landscape tab
sculpt tool settings brush settings
target layers yeah
um so
in the layers you'll see like just
uh something empty so if you press the
plus icon it says create layer info i've
already done this in my landscape by the
way um but
once you have those created you'll be
able to
to
paint some textures onto the landscape
okay i'm trying to find where this plus
button is
you're like such a noob right now
it's all good no no that's so good
does it add components to the landscape
uh
sculpt
paint
here we go
i had to go to the paint tab
up in here so it was that manage and i
wanted to go to paint
and there i can see these textures okay
so it looks like i already have them
there
um
[Music]
and i probably want to get rid of this
texture for
can i just delete that i think i think
texture 4 you'll have to leave there for
now
so i think for my project i was able to
get i can get i've got my contact
shadows working so i guess i can show
that off quickly uh okay i'm running
into
errors and problems but here let's
switch over
all right
i'm just gonna
go oh i think we
visible
i can't hear you
oh there we go oh i haven't
haven't done anything yeah i thought you
were talking and i couldn't hear you
yeah we're saying okay
oh no
okay um
so yeah i've got my contact shadows
enabled at the moment so if i
go ahead and turn this on and off
in the directional light
it's hard to see kind of but
maybe the textures are too small to
scale
the light's not
um but you can sort of see like you know
like where the normal like has a little
bump there's like it's just a short
shadow coming down i might i might work
on making that a bit more prominent but
can you slide through it again before
and after
so that's oh yeah with and that's
without
so this is currently without or this is
currently with
i'm not sure
it's not it's not very noticeable
maybe i'll work on it
so the darker flatter version is without
and then like the more like
sharpened version is with i i might work
on making a better example for that
because it's not too not too obvious but
um
i yeah i really wanted to just talk
about like uh material contact shadows
because when i first discovered it i was
like oh this is amazing all this detail
um this is something that you discovered
from the uh
the
the australia pack right is that what
you said
yes yeah yeah so um from the australia
pack on the unreal under marketplace
which is for free
i downloaded that and i looked through
the materials because um the creator of
the australian pack uh
andrew spamberg hamilton he um
he was like a developer of dice for a
long time he like has a lot of
experience i just really wanted to dive
into his material design see what see
what he's doing like see what like the
the best material design is and yeah
that's how i
learned the technique
that's awesome yeah this is all free too
by the way you can download this for
free and hop in
and explore this and like you just
basically reverse engineered
what uh what andrew did
to discover that technique that's cool
yeah
that's awesome this is such a good mind
yeah go ahead yeah yeah it's an amazing
pack it's like
yeah amazing um
i
yeah i think i might try and move on to
like getting my landscape like height
maps and looking good
um if you
if you feel like you're struggling just
give me a shout sounds good
yeah go for it
so i might
let's see
i might just cheat it
yeah so for the people for people who
haven't been watching since the start
we're making um
making like a nepalese inspired winter
landscape um if my screen's still up
i'll just pull the video off again yeah
i got you
yeah just in case so
um
these
uh vlogs by craig adams he does a lot of
hiking videos and we found like this
nice like nepalese
uh
like hiking trail um so i thought i
would have a go at trying to recreate it
um so yeah that's what we're doing at
the moment obviously
not
very far yet but
we'll just we'll just see how we go
so you're trying to throw i think it's
important height map or displacement
yeah
yeah i
um i was gonna create another landscape
from scratch i just deleted my old one
and then i'm gonna import
files
yeah during the stream has made me
realize how
how bad i am
dude it's
it's really difficult to do
it's very difficult to focus on like
very minut things and it's like you feel
like people
you're like oh who cares about this one
little thing but like
people actually love it they
eat this stuff up man
it's freaking awesome to
yeah we'll we'll for sure he's he's
really good at it
i wonder if he's still here
yeah he's he's killer i've ever i
actually never watched
this uh one of his streams before but
definitely
would like to in the future here
yeah i'm almost i it sucks that i miss
most of your streams as well because
most for the most part they're like from
from 1am to 4am
yeah it's all good yeah if i'm pulling a
bender and like working on something i
always have it like in the corner
so what are you up to right now what are
you what are you doing in your scene
uh just i've got my height map in which
is looking alright i think i might just
go ahead
we've got some weird looking i mean i
think
i know i know what's wrong here like i
i've imported a file that's like not
nearly high enough resolution uh so
we've got all these lines looking like
look like minecraft here yeah
yeah but i think i can fix this pretty
easily if i just like going
to smooth the landscape
sculpting tool
i think i'll i think i'll
somewhat go into like con concentration
mode so i can get something together
i think after this i'm gonna i'm gonna
jump into like getting my my sky dome
set up so like with my hdri
sounds good i'll be moving some pieces
around
on my sounds good
once you've got uh once you've
essentially once you've got your asset
set up and you've got your
landscape working like being able to
paint materials i think we'll get our
skybox setup
sounds good
it looks like a bit depth issue
yeah
yeah it was just like a like an awful
quality jpeg
but you know like even even if it's a
bad quality jpeg like it's enough to
just get like the outline there and then
you can go in with the smooth tool and
just like make everything look much more
smooth
right now
sweet
it's a good tip
because then you're essentially going to
throw your own landscape you're going to
throw your landscape material on top of
that that's the one that like switches
between three to four materials right
that right now i was going to mention
quickly where i got my height map from
um
i use a website that i named so i'll
just look up quickly
it's called tantrams.get
heightmapper and on my screen i've got
it now it's like a um
pretty much a world map of that's been
heightmapped and so you can you can zoom
in on any part of it that you'd like and
then it you can extract you know you can
render out like a
short screenshot of the height map which
is pretty cool um i found it doesn't
have a lot of really close detail but
um but yeah for large landscapes i found
it to be to be pretty helpful like for
this um
for this scene i
just got like a little
excerpt of like the himalayas i have no
idea which part of the himalayas but i
just like chose a little spot
that's incredible could you do do you
can you actually grab that link for the
audience can you
put a chat
yeah yeah
that's a great resource
yeah i forgot how i how i found it
actually
twice
um yeah i found like
there are tons of resources for height
maps but i found it's just so easy to
just like open a browser tab and
yeah just get a high map just like that
that's amazing
let's see yeah i'm having trouble here
it's going against air it says this
layer has no layer info assigned yet you
must create or assign a layer info
before you can paint this layer
okay okay so
um on my screen now i've got my
landscape um
option open and so you've got your
target layers right and you've got your
like slots your four slots
yes four slots here so see how csos has
none after each of the labels yeah
so on the far right there's a little
plus sign which is create layer info
yeah
and so
[Music]
with that you create a weight blended
layer
and
you can save that anywhere in your
your content directory
and after that it'll essentially
reference that layout
oh okay
so does that sound clear have you is
that working
yeah that is that should be yeah
oh snap okay yep
i'm seeing things now that's fantastic
so the reason we go weight-bended layer
instead of a non-weight blended layer is
because
in most of my landscape materials i like
to reference the displacement map
and that just gives a really nice um
transition i suppose between materials
it references the height map and then it
like
sort of overlaps them in a more natural
way
sweet
i'm so excited to be learning all this
stuff and
i can't wait to like figure out this
workflow here
dang i'm still getting the thing
slayer has no layering fluid sign yet i
have signed all four layers
what is going on
oh that's strange
i mean for me i
yeah once the layer was created and i
can see it in my
my landscape tab it doesn't say none it
says the layer that i just made and then
i'm able to
do some painting
i don't know why it still says
nay
uh target layers
see i don't think i'm supposed to do
anything else
oh shoot someone someone in the chat
just says one of my best friends
uh was part of the leads of the mission
that got the data for the height map
how cool is that oh snap wait i know i
know this guy
i know hunter
oh snap
that's awesome
that's awesome wow that's super crazy
small world
is this house working in directx 11 yes
um
me at least i i'm not going to be
relying on any brake tracing for this
project we're just going with um
traditional dynamic lighting
hey caves did you get that
height map link by the way i don't think
i saw it in the chat yeah i posted it in
the chat oh i can do it again you did
wait soda did you see it
i i guess i don't come up as a moderator
so it sort of blends in but i don't i
didn't see a link that's weird
you can send it to me on discord
okay yeah i'll do that quickly
oh sorry about the coughing i just like
swallowed my coffee the wrong way oh
dude you're all good
sweet
all right pinned it
that's a really cool
a really cool
service they got here for free too what
the heck
how are you doing how are you i'm just
about yeah i'm i'm just about ready like
i've got a landscape that looks like
ugly at the moment but i'm just about
ready to like start laying down some
trees
all right i'm gonna need your help i
need i need you to help a noob out here
so i am
currently at a point where like i'm
trying to paint but it's not it's still
giving me this error
that this layer has no
layer info assigned yet and then you
have to create or assign a layer info
before you can paint the layer but
everything on the left
is basically
assigned
i added the plus sign to everything okay
so i'm not ready so
it doesn't say none anymore underneath
the label no
okay
is that a
white blended layer or the other
the other type
no this is the first option the one that
says parentheses normal
okay
oh man i'm sorry yeah i'm not sure um
it's probably probably just doing some
noob thing that's like
um
i mean if you want you can screenshot on
discord really quick oh
let me just try and restart it let me
restart my program i'm gonna switch over
good work
all right in that case at the moment i'm
just um tweaking my landscape materials
because everything's looking a bit funny
at the moment
i'm holding you back caves
no no
not at all i love i love this vibe i
love this is like a one-on-one tutorial
it's great
it's awesome it's awesome to be able to
yeah just like i'll give you a kickstart
i know that you've been
lying down unreal for a long time like
um
yeah i'd love to be able to help you
like make the stuff that you want to
make like there's nothing worse than
just like you know dealing with a
program just like not knowing where the
buttons are
yeah it's tough at first you know it's
like you're crawling through the program
hey it works now man
a little restart yeah a little restart
i'll do it oh nice for some reason it's
gray though there's like parts that are
like gray like camouflage or something
but
i that's fine we can
we can move on
that is strange why is it doing that
you see this by chance
like looks like camouflage
should be white right it's snow
is it this one is it
no it's not that
oh i think i know what you mean um yeah
so if you open your material instance
that's because of the macro variation
that i included and i think by default i
accidentally set that to full so if you
search
in the details panel macro
you'll be able to set your macro
intensity to zero
dude
somebody knows what they're talking
about
snap yeah yeah yeah when you're ready uh
should we get into like uh skybox and
like
let's do it
is she all right cool let's do it
so let's let's go through this
together because we're both sort of on
the same
level so if you go into
engine content in your content browser
search sky
yeah
and drag that into the scene and go to
details and scale that up to life
okay he said one more time you said in
the content browser do what now
the content browser so
you're able to find engine content
there's like a panel on the very side
that you can pop out
like a list and
from there you select engine content and
then you can search within that folder
engine content i in content the content
folder let me switch to you while you
show
it's so tiny so
i'm gonna get this over here
i can zoom in it's just this pad this
tab here you can like select this um
window yeah okay yeah i'm on that
and then select engine content and then
from there in the search
bar you can search skype here
oh weird i'm not seeing that folder that
engine content folder
so does it just like content for you
yeah just this content yeah
i wonder if that's like a project
setting that i changed like years ago
yeah just contact
like it's unreal for you i could add a
feature or a pack content pack
starter content or something it's like i
don't know if that's this is what i need
to be doing but
probably not
just such perfect settings anyway
here you go for it you add it and then i
i think i have enough
info to like add a x uh
uh uh height or what is it exponential
height fog i can add some of that and
like
work my size
i can get i can get that far but yeah
why don't you why don't you go for it
i've just put in my um
sky sphere and i just like to take that
mesh from the content files because it
says you haven't
bought it yourself
and now in our masters
folder i've got a material that's set up
for
skyspheres so i'm gonna
create an instance
oh if i got the wrong material oh no
so
i'll be able to put in i'll be able to
put something in but it's not going to
be projected correctly i'm just going to
import my
sky texture quickly
oh william's william's still in the chat
and he's giving me so he says you need
to go to view options in the bottom
right of your content browser
show engine content
yes check box show engine content
william you're a life saver thank you
much appreciated so now on the left
i can actually
i can see if dang my head is in the way
big old head is in the way
but i have that pack now engine content
and you said sky sphere
uh matt are you still there
yep i'm still there uh what was here
what was the thing to search for
yeah
sky sphere
and it's a folder is that right sky
atmosphere uh it's a mesh it's a mesh um
so
so if you have the engine content
selected in the left pane you should be
able to search skies here and it should
be the first option oh boy it's like a
static match you can just drag that into
the scene
i'm just getting
this must be by okay look this must be
rough for people who know what's going
on
apologies
i am i am my fingernails i'm just
hanging on by my fingernails scraping
trying to keep up with a master working
his magic right now
oh
man oh man we're gonna get there
we're gonna get there
i appreciate everyone's patience
this is what happens when you don't know
how to use this program you know this is
what happens you notice how to use this
program you make a full year i mean the
thing
the thing that works me about unreal is
like you know that that option was just
like a thing hidden away in project
settings you know and you never know to
like search for a way to find it
um i often i found that some like
some really crucial settings just boil
down to that you know that one check box
and you have no idea where it is oh
that's that's question brutal
it's like you move into a new house it's
a mansion it's like that's the biggest
house you've ever been to and all your
stuff is just scattered around and
you're like i thought
like how am i supposed to know is up in
the attic in this drawer under the
floorboard like how am i supposed to
know where these buttons are but you
know
you know you hang out with matt you hang
out with uh with william and
you watch their videos and their
tutorials and
and you know then you figure out oh that
is under the floorboard i'm gonna move
it into my pocket i'm gonna have it in
my pocket for next time so
[Laughter]
thanks for your patience dude i think i
found it though i don't know it's a
problem skysphere material
um
which one there's four sky spheres
um it's just the it's just the static
mesh that you need um
now
and i just drag it out into the sky
uh yeah we're on to the landscape we're
on to the lake sorry wish i could i wish
i could see
um
what's the what's the name of it i have
i have four names here i have uh
uh editor sky spheres guy sphere
material sm sky sphere sm sky i have two
sm sky sky skyspheres
i'm searching it everyone's like
everyone's editing
skysphere
full alert editor skysphere
okay and i just drag that into the scene
okay my sky went gray so
looks a little
uh
let's see
where is that even
oh you just drag it i think drag it onto
the landscape so this place like right
in the middle
i think i'm i'm probably doing the wrong
thing
you gotta drag bp skysphere okay
thank you chat
i really appreciate you bp skysphere
all right um yeah okay
this guy just turned all orange and
stuff
i just don't know where it went though
because it's like i'm applying it to
something is it an actor that is like in
the scene
or is it a material it's like
essentially an actor with the normals
that are inverted so it can only be
viewed from the inside
show me on your screen
what does that look like where like
where is that where would you click on
it
the moment
i i've got it scaled up 500 times so
that's why it's like covering the sky
but if i put it right back down to one
you'll see just like a dome like a weird
extra projector all right and show me
where you're getting that from
all right so engine content
uh such sky sphere
there's this editor sky speed here that
i just dragged in editor sky sphere yeah
okay so i put that on the landscape just
so it's like placed in the center and i
can work with it
um and then in the details panel when
you've got that selected scale it up
around 500 times you can do more if you
want all right give me a second
and that essentially just wraps the
entire scene
inside the inside sphere
okay it's weird because it's not i'm not
i don't think i'm seeing it in my
content browser
or sorry the world outliner i'm not
seeing it in my world outliner so i
don't know where it is in my scene
okay if it's not in your in your
world outliner it might not be in scene
properly
like uh if you if you drag it onto the
like the background where there is no
background it'll it might not like
be placed correctly
i might i'm probably doing this wrong
because the chat is yelling at me to
like
sky
uh
bp sky sphere yeah i don't know if i'm
like
it's weird because like based on your
screen
i'm dragging the correct thing based off
of like
this discord view of the screen share of
my other computer
um
but
yeah i i don't i don't know
it just looks like a massive gray box
this guy goes
wait look what is being added
oh i see okay no there it is but why the
heck is it grayed out like that
why is everything out
that's strange
jeez
cursed
uh i wish yeah it's such a shame i can't
see a real update real-time update of
your screen um otherwise i'd be able to
help you
so
i just went full screen on me but
everything else is greyed out besides oh
it's precur
it's because i'm in paint mode i would
assume
oh maybe that's my bad i need to switch
to select oh
good so select would be shift one
there we go and i think this thing is
like that's my bad
utterly massive
which is why it's encompassing the whole
screen
okay so it's just a gray blob
right now is what this thing is
i guess i may as well mention like it's
slightly with the newer versions unreal
it's slightly less obvious which like
which which mode you're in currently
like i've just i'm just so used to
pressing like shift f shift one shift
two shift three to change between um but
yeah that's that's a prominent thing
like if you're in the foliage editing
mode and you want to move an object you
would have to
change to
um shift one which is just like the
object's
editing mode yeah that's before you can
do anything so good to know
oh man
yeah that's my bad man sorry today
it's all good man it's like like i said
my fingernails are bleeding from
crawling
uh and just trying to make it work um
but you know i think i just took my
first step so i know
exactly
that i i need to be
in select mode
shift one
in order to move stuff around so okay yo
we got
our editor skysphere up in here
i'm maxing it out like it came in as
it's totally encompassing my entire
scene um it's just a gray void
which also yeah
so what i did was i went into
masters in the content browser masters
backdrops and then i've got a material
called
uh backdrop
which i
created an instance and then
from that instance i feed it in a custom
uh
custom texture
now i actually forgot to include like
there's a version of the material that
lets you reference a hdri
and then it maps it
around you but uh
turns out i've got to include that
version of materials so for now it's
just an image reference so if you have
any
hdri that you can bring in as an image
like a jpeg or png
oh interesting
it will work it just means the bottom
half of the of the sphere will have to
be obscured like on my screen if i
disable the fog
um like a repeat to the clouds
gotcha okay so that's a jpeg or you have
an hdri and i need to get a jpeg
i i used a jpeg i
had a jpeg version of the same image i
was gonna use
okay
okay
i can i can find something as we
as we move forward
cool
so yeah what else yeah you got that sky
you got that sky coming up i got it i
got it figured out enough like i'm not
going to take any more time to like find
a j i can find a jpeg
at some point but gray right now is fine
i don't really need
unless it's crucial to like figuring out
what the lighting is here because i can
see that the sun is poking through
so we're gonna probably are we are we
is this hdri like faking the sky
essentially and then
uh or this jpeg rather and then we
actually choose the lighting based off
the sun is that how it works
yeah essentially i mean ideally you
would like line up the direction of the
sun with wherever the sun is coming from
in the hdri yeah of course
like obviously actually
like this is just my process you don't
have to use a hdri backdrop for your
scene like a lot of people especially
recently are utilizing like all the
volumetric fog stuff all the sky
atmosphere stuff which looks amazing
um
yeah i i just wanted to go with this
because
i really enjoy using like a really high
quality picture instead of using the
like cloud volume metrics because i love
the cloud volume metrics but
i found that when you compare the two
it's like
with a static image you just get much
like much more detail in some spots and
everything looks like overall just a bit
more real
sweet i like on my screen at the moment
i've got just like yeah some really nice
nicely shaped clouds
um
yeah so that's what i thought i would
just like
just do things the way i usually handle
things yeah absolutely actually on your
side if you felt like just like dragging
in a sky atmosphere asset and then
a volumetric cloud as that you'll have
like a very similar effect
and you'll have like your own custom sky
which is probably actually a much easier
way of doing things
yeah let me let me let me give that a
shot so you said a sky atmosphere
actor
um and what else so
i guess you could hide the current
skyscraper if you want um but now
the skylight
or the uh the sky
yeah the mesh space
you would go into your details panel and
and
uncheck visible or you can just hide it
from the
rolled out liner yeah yeah
and so yeah just drag in a sky
atmosphere asset and then a volumetric
cloud asset and i think you'll have to
go to your directional light and then
search
here and then you have to check
atmosphere sunlight in your
directional
yeah
um that that's pretty sweet we got some
clouds up in here um
the first thing you said to add was a
what a
uh
a volumetric cloud in a what
and a sky atmosphere
got you
and that stuff yeah it's so it's so
handy so it's so useful for getting
something that looks automatically like
really great
um and it like reacts to like the
direction of the sun and everything um
it's awesome
yeah it's like it's it's super great if
it comes out with like so much amazing
stuff man
ah i'm i am oh wow that's really cool
that's great these are you want to stick
with that
yeah i'm gonna stick with this i'm gonna
i'm gonna go like
easy mode
oh no i reckon like you'll have some
like dynamic movement stuff going on
better than my scene so yeah
um all right i reckon for now let's
let's go through like our lighting setup
i'm gonna i'm just gonna like place some
trees down
and um
do a bit of painting
cool
and then i'll i'll get straight into
lighting because that we can both do at
the same time
sounds good so i'll play some stuff as
well
yeah if you want um
so
[Music]
have you used the foliage so much
a little of shift three right
yep shift three and then i've just
dragged in i've just selected a bunch of
static meshes from my content browser
and i've dragged those into that page
now i'm just going to start
painting some stuff
so you can drop your trees in there and
stuff
yeah yeah i'm just dropping a bunch of
trees for the moment
all right i'll try and do the same
and then how do you do like would you
add sticks to that as well or would you
oh
yeah
i mean if you want something um yeah so
you just did the same thing as me like
uh
like it's all really dense at the start
you just like dial down the density um
down to like i've got like point zero
three
oh
and
another tip is to
uh in
foliage tab you select all of your
instances and then go to the option that
says align to normal it means all of
your trees
uh won't bend the direction of the
landscape so i think you've got a flat
landscape so
it should be fine but in my case i've
got a bunch of hills so it just helps
having um
having all the trees being upright
instead of
pointing
yes direction yes exactly aligned to
normal is checked okay so
basically
if i add hills later
they will stay upright as well is that
correct
uh
yeah yeah that's right sweet okay
so i i've found out that a lot of the
trees aren't particularly optimized like
i have a whole process for like creating
billboards um
for trees and foliage that
will utilize it effectively um but for
now i don't think i've five times
through that
yeah that's fair that's fair yeah
billboards for those who don't know uh
uh is an effective way of just like
saving performance when you've got trees
in the distance it essentially swaps the
3d model out with a flat plane or like a
very simple
uh mesh um
and then
the goal is to get that transition
between the full quality mesh and the
billboard to be as seamless as possible
so
once you um once you're moving away from
it it like transitions and then you get
that performance boost as soon as the
high quality model is loaded out that's
incredible man
have you ever thought of
making tutorials because i feel like
this knowledge that you're dishing out
here like we could each one of these
things that you're saying could just be
unpacked and like
dived into
oh it's it's very nice for you to say
that um i might do someday i just i
guess whenever i sit down at the
computer i really just all i can be
motivated to do is just like work on
work on something yeah like a project as
opposed to making a tutorial but
um but maybe someday like i
like i definitely have some tricks that
i that i that it took a while for me to
search for yeah
uh that could be useful for
a lot of people but yeah it's just a
matter of i i'm
i don't know if i'm a good public
speaker or not i don't know if i'm good
at that whole like youtube format and
making tutorials
hey guys you just gotta like amp
yourself up you gotta start with hey
guys really intensely hey guys what's up
and then you just you know then
the rest just flows you know
yeah
you do ten push-ups before you record
which is hilarious because that's why
literally i was like yeah i just do some
push-ups before we uh
before we go live
yeah that's a great a great
recommendation like i'm gonna start
doing that before before my zoom calls
maybe
it helps like
uh this stream
i didn't need to just because
it's more of a chill situation but when
you gotta like get all hyped and stuff
you know it's a great way to get going
um question for you i know there's a
noob this is a noob question so
in i'm in shift f3 mode i am in foliage
painting mode
that is confirmed um
but my brush went away i can't see
anything anymore and i'm clicking on the
the landscape and nothing is
is spawning do you know why
i'm not too sure it might be because
your um voltage instances aren't
selected so in the in the pain you'll
have to go over and like take all those
boxes where each of the trees are
they're all ticked yeah
okay
um in that case
uh just check like the size of your
brush which comes up in like the tab
yeah i hadn't touched that that that
remains the same density was the only
thing that's changed
that's that's strange and i have paint
selected the paint brush selected
i mean you say you say i would be good
at tutorials but i i'm sorry that i
can't like help out these kinds of
problems
yeah
i'm just sort of watching
a couple seconds late
i wonder if i have to have the landscape
selected
your your landscape's looking nice
though like normals picking up the light
stuff lots of painting going on
yeah we'll figure it out we'll get there
i think i've almost like made a
landscape too big like
definitely getting some frame hitches
yeah keep it when your cake is small
keep it super small
i might suggest like in your case you're
probably better off just going with that
small square that i put in the project
oh that's exactly i'm not even gonna i'm
not even gonna try and go outside of
this zone
that's pretty sweet
is that working again for you or no my
brush is gone but it's all good you keep
doing your thing
i think we can both um we can both do
our lighting setups at the same time
that's for sure yeah definitely a lot to
go into
so just a time check so it's uh
nearly 3 a.m for me here i think
i'm very happy to keep going i really
want to get something um somewhat
complete
yeah why don't you just bust it out just
like you you go off like
i'll i'll be chilling back here you know
dabbling with this thing but why don't
you just tear it up
you know take
as much time as you have to put
something together and like
explain as you can as uh if you know as
you can and if possible but yeah go for
it
right um but i guess we may as well do
our like lighting setup together because
that's essentially yeah we're both ready
let's do it yeah
um so
so first off i always change all my
lights to movable and this is like a
trick that i
overlooked when i was starting and it
frustrated the hell out of me so
yeah if you go to movable that
essentially means that like the light is
essentially dynamic it has no built-in
effects what you see is what the final
product will look like
so with your with the skylight and
directional light we both both
move
to show actually i want to show distance
fields so
i think that's worth sharing um so i
enabled that within the project before i
send them over so it should be enabled
um but for those who want to try out
distance field you have to go into the
project settings and then just enable
this fields
restart
so in the directional light
there is a section called distance field
shadows and you'll if you check that
and then push the
cascaded shadow maps distance all the
way down to zero
and we're not seeing anything at the
moment it's because i
maybe haven't enabled it
but this instilled uh like a really
a really cheap way of getting like some
nice
uh
nice detailed shadows like with
different fields if you mess around with
your parameters in your directional
light
right with the source angle you can get
like this nice like
uh i guess it looks somewhat messy on my
stream but you got this nice like
transitional effect between objects that
are really close to the ground and
objects that are a bit further away
so you'll notice that on my screen
you've got like a
this tree here when in comparison to the
trees in the distance those trees like
the shadows blurred out because it's um
further away from the landscape surface
but
uh with the tree that's really close you
get like these nice like sharp shadows
and also by disabling
the to get to get uh distilled shadows
enabled or like visible all the way up
to the camera you have to
reduce the cascaded shadow maps
distance to zero
um
can you show honor
you show the difference between those
okay so
i'm gonna okay yeah
i'm just save all the contact shadows
so at the moment we've got distance
field shadows and then if i turn on
cascade it looks like that
but you'll notice like at the very base
it's not very detailed the shutoff show
sort of cuts off yeah it looks like it's
floating
yeah so if i turn that all the way down
to zero you get like
still a bit of a cut off but the idea is
um yeah much more crisp shadows with
objects that are really close to the
ground and then it sort of fades off
into like a more
natural gradient
i think the reason this is looking
fairly messy at the moment on my screen
is because
um
because a lot of these trees maybe
haven't had their
distance field shadow resolution set to
the right amount like if you have all
these artifacts it means you have to
bump up your
this is filled shadow resolution
that makes sense to some people
that's definitely definitely a lot of
settings yeah that need to be totally
aware that i'm like jumping up and down
between difficulty levels like every
minute so i apologize for that
i'll just be constantly asking questions
so
that's um
so basically that harsh shadow line that
connects this tree to the ground
that setting
is a distance field setting that's what
you're
is that correct yeah that i guess that
is also possible with ray tracing but a
way to get that without ray tracing is
to use distance from shadows actually i
think i think distance field shadows are
a form of ray tracing actually it is ray
trace
there are ratio shadows but
it's such a it's such like a performance
buddhist style like without using ray
tracing i found if i disable cascade
shadows which is the traditional
dynamic shadowing method like i
automatically get like so many frames
back it's it's great
this is awesome so what you're doing is
you're optimizing your scene
this your whole workflow is based around
optimizing
your scene to make it look like it's
photo reel to make it look like it's ray
tracing
but it's not essentially exactly yeah
yeah like i because i want my
environments to be
efficient from the ground up i just
always start with that as a base like
um
yeah and once you have that you can
always like tweak values and make things
more expensive later on but
um but yeah the whole idea is to just
like you know look at photos try and try
and emulate realistic lights in like the
most efficient way possible and then
that's how sort of how i put um
environments together
what are some resources for people that
like you're talking about
some like very advanced stuff here
some very
uh
very specific stuff
where
do you go i don't remember where i
learned this originally um
i watched a whole bunch of epic uh live
streams outlining all these features
there is one video particularly on
distance fields which is really useful
um
but
uh yeah like
sometimes it's really hard to be aware
of these these features like you'll find
that
like for me contact shadows i didn't
know where
i wasn't aware they existed until
like much later than i would have wanted
um but it was just like you know as soon
as i knew what they were i could like
search documentation search like the
video coverage
and then that gave like a good um
amount of information on how to use it
okay yeah that makes sense that makes
sense so i hope you all taken notes
write down these things you got to look
into and dive deep you know you can do
it with the documentation or just you
know youtube your stuff
um but from this point
where would you go from here
okay from here i have sort of got like a
vague
scene put together with dan with snaps
oh trees yeah i'm just gonna try and put
in some more details from here on like
scatter some assets around um
i was just about to use the landscape
tool to
apply a noise painter to get some more
like detailed variation on the ground
that's sort of a trick i like to use
sweet um
yeah i wanted to say as a disclaimer
like keeping in mind all the stuff i
design is that i want to be able to use
for like real-time applications so i'd
love to turn my environments into
playable demos and like vr software and
things like that
so obviously a lot of these techniques
aren't necessarily applicable if you're
planning on making a render or
or
producing a scene
it's great though with different
like outputs in mind yeah it's such a
different workflow from
you know from what i'm used to
and i think there's so much to learn
from this so
you know as we as we get as we approach
the future and and get into the
metaverse and whatnot like
creating these virtual environments
to play back in vr
is going to be huge
and i think knowing all these things to
to optimize your scene
for for that kind of setup
is going to be very very very valuable
yeah i agree i agree and i think um
i think even for even for pushing out
like
uh normal renders like if you have if
you have a really large environment
sometimes it's only possible to work
with a project that has a large
environment if it's optimized like if
you
if you build it without um
being careful about like poly counts or
texture extra resolution and things
um or if you like aim for like the very
highest target of quality right from the
from the beginning yeah
it's often really hard to work with like
a huge environment like the good thing
about unreal is all of this like
optimization stuff is built in if you
wanted to have a huge environment you
can
work on one area and then as soon as you
zoom out the detail is loaded out and
then you zoom into another area on the
other end of the map several kilometers
away and then as soon as you put the
camera there all the detail is there
that's awesome like that's essentially
yeah like essentially what makes unreal
stand out from other renderers i think
like
other renderers you have to like stay
somewhat confined within like your
your play space like
uh you're not able to like make
landscapes that are kilometers long and
have that filled with grass just because
you know it's like impossible to work
with
um but yeah unreal is just about
honorable and unity actually both unreal
and unity being real time major games
it's sort of um
it makes sense it makes sense
it's such a cool like if if you can
figure out how
this sandbox works it's the coolest
thing
to to explore and like build from
and there
there are certainly times where like
i i can get frustrated and
overwhelmed with the amount of stuff
that unreal has to offer and
i really appreciate you like
you know helping us out and and pointing
us in the right direction where it
at least y'all you know like i was
saying please take notes and
and look up these things
because he's pointing you in a lot of
super solid directions here
and of course we only have limited a
limited amount of time here
um
but
there's just so much to unpack i feel
like we could just do this for hours and
hours but it's almost 4 a.m where you're
at so
we're getting to the point here where
we'll probably want to like start
start building out the scene
and
hopefully getting to the point where we
can export an exe for people to to hop
into the world and like
and explore for themselves
yeah i think i think with a bit of a
push i might i might go into
concentration mode for a bit and just
like yeah see what i can do do it that's
all good i'll switch over to my screen
and uh
and i'll i'll
see what i can do here um i'm trying to
go with
the simplest version
of a scene here so i'm probably going to
crank the fog up a whole bunch
at a certain point here
i'm just gonna place these around and
you know what i might even
go with a
i've been in unreal five
recently so going back to four is like
it's not that bad actually
so yeah learning planning unreal five
would probably be the right thing to do
at this point i think
almost all the engines are pretty
similar all in all but um
yeah i think everything will be almost
solely in in unreal five from here
onwards
um i just use unreal four because yeah
i'm slightly unfamiliar with real five
and they use it a handful of times and
um a lot of the
yeah lighting options are much more
stable than unreal engine 4 considering
unreal engine 5 early access
yeah
it's just so beautiful though like
the way everything reacts in unreal 5
and the way everything works together
it just works
seamlessly
and
there are times where it glitches out
but everything's kind of like preset for
you which is cool
yeah yeah and with like all of their
like aluminum
like lighting i i was amazed at how like
how quick you can get like really nice
results
yeah just by like placing a couple
lights and you're seeing it's like not
it's absurd
oh man have you seen the um have you
seen the matrix awakens demo from from
epic
not yet no
oh man i saw that yesterday like my mind
was blown i i work with unreal
all the time and my mind was fluent by
that project like
they've just been like keeping it secret
for a whole year they suddenly bust out
like an open a photorealistic open world
matrix city yeah it's nuts and is it
free to download and hop into
yeah i think it's um ps5 and xbox only
so i can't try it i just have to
experience it through a youtube video
but uh same same
but it's like the culmination of like
all the tech and all the money they've
put into like advancing all the stuff
they've been working on just like
culminates into like that project
they and they went ahead and recreated
like some scenes from the original
matrix at the start of the
side of the video which i thought were
excerpts from the film i thought they'd
just taken and put in videos but no
they're like
like real time unreal engine 5 like
recreations of
scenes from the matrix
jeez
that's insane yeah salmon uh
i think nick it was sam sam and peter
were telling me about it yesterday
um
and i i didn't know what it was like
because i i saw unreal just kept like
pushing it on their instagram and i'm
like
okay i don't
i didn't click it i just didn't click it
but
i thought
i thought yeah they're just trying to
push their like matrix license
yeah but actually it's well worth it
like the project is
i'm surprised they didn't share anything
about it until now it's like a massive
project dang it that it like didn't get
leaked or anything
just looking through the chat we got um
this exam here on the east coast yeah oh
thanks for sticking around
uh 2 am in vietnam
that's legit yes this is just about this
is just about the only time like where
everyone is awake sort of
i guess i wouldn't normally be awake but
yeah right it's like
we we picked the perfect time we picked
the exact perfect time to do this
the only honestly it was here in wa
someone someone's in in perth someone's
in west australia really
iron hudson
oh snap
oh yeah everyone everyone check out the
epic uh
yeah the epic project the matrix awakens
uh the dialogue is kind of corny
actually in parts of it but you want to
watch the end of the video because
that's where they just like
walk around the environment and showcase
everything
all right so i'm gonna go back into
concentration see what i can get done
i'm happy to spend like another 30
minutes on this that's
that's plenty yeah that's plenty
i'll bug you about fog settings later
but i'm gonna get everything placed
first
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get stuck into
that pretty soon as well um
because i i haven't like
i haven't got all that much to work with
at the moment i think the fog will like
definitely
clean up the ambience a little bit it's
gonna save my render
i gotta cheat it so hard i'm gonna like
get that super wide
aspect ratio
was it like 27
64 by 27
i think
all right let's see if that paintbrush
works
i'm going to mention something quickly
um
so i i've hooked up all my materials to
work with a snow shader so i've got a
global parameter that i can adjust
so i can import a whole bunch of assets
that don't essentially have snow on them
and then once i enable like the shader
or i turn up my values
i can get like some nice detailed snow
appearing on like the surface of the
assets what the heck
okay okay what is that what's going on
there how does that work
um so
so
the master material the master surface
material references a
material function and that function
essentially
takes the
uh the pixel normal so each pixel with
the direction it's facing it takes that
normal and decides how far upwards it's
facing and if it's facing far enough
upwards it like colors it completely
white
and also turns the roughness all the way
up
okay so with that you get an effect that
like the surface that looks like it's
facing upwards it turns that white and
then that's how you get
uh like a nice overlay of snow and then
it's also influenced by the normal
texture so that's how you get like a
like a detailed like
gradient you can see on the rock there's
like little bits of snow
that's great that's very similar like in
octane
a fall off node
essentially where you're like masking
out just the parts of the
the geometry that are facing
up towards the sky
and you can
use that as a mask for whatever material
you want
so that's cool that you can do it here
unreal it's just a bit more a bit more
of a process if people wanted to look
that up if people wanted to dive deeper
into how to do that what would they
google
um
i don't think of how i
had
taught me to remember how i learned it
but
um but no not specifically not the
specific tutorial but like just the
wording
um yeah no i think like there are lots
of different ways to achieve it i think
just search like
you know like snow
no material function something along
those lines um because everyone has a
different way that they approach it yeah
and yeah if you find a youtube video
with something that looks appealing then
it's and yeah you can follow along with
that
there's no material function right cool
i've realized now that like my
performance is like
fairly [ __ ] like i'm only getting
i'm just getting my friends
30 frames a second
pretty rough um
most of these trees i think are pretty
high quality i'd have to go through and
like produce the
led selection oh boy
um actually i could go into like some
console commands like you've got um
like useful useful console commands for
optimization uh like
yes i did so then that like essentially
uh it essentially changes the difference
the distance that at which each tree
swaps out a lower quality
led ah i see and in doing so that
changed like you naturally changed all
the trees at once so now i went from 30
frames that was like 50 frames just from
doing that
and there's almost no like no difference
um there's also
huge
in lod so i said minimum led to one that
means it doesn't reference led zero
anymore it goes straight to led1 even at
the closest
distance was it was that the force lod
uh that was
foliage dot min lod
one
um
what do you say how are you going do you
think we should get into like some
fog and atmospherics
uh wherever you think you're at if you
want to scatter some like ground stuff
um
yeah i might i might do that in between
um but
sure i've got some ground stuff set up
yeah yeah if you think that when you're
in for uh yourself if you're still
working we can do it in like 10 minutes
no i i mean if if this works for you i
think it's something that i need to do
anyway so if you feel comfortable going
over that right now then let's do
it i just think at the moment like i'm a
little bit like not that i'm displeased
with the scene i think i got some nice
like atmospherics and colors going but
i just realized like there are so many
like things i need to tweak like you've
got like the the ground texture that's
the wrong scale you've got like um
you know just like all these material
values that i could have like spent some
time just like changing um and i'm not
sure if i'll get time to change all
those so
in that case um
yeah let's let's see what we can do with
lighting and effects because
in my opinion i think the lighting and
like post-processing
are done on the scene like always pulls
the most weight you know like you can
you can import as many high quality
models textures as you want like get
those looking perfect but
just change a couple of parameters in
your post process and that makes a huge
difference like bigger than anything
else that you've done so
um agreed it all comes down to lighting
lighting and effects yeah
yeah absolutely
okay
so i'm going to go ahead and drag and
post process volume into the theme
and
in the details panel i'll go ahead and
unbound so that it applies to
the camera no matter where it is in the
scene not just in the whole
game with that um
you can just like make tweaks and then
decide how your scene's gonna look
actually we should do fog before we
start that's the only saving grace for
me
at this point
no it's going to be the same for me as
well actually like i
yeah we'll see so i'm going to have you
you've got your exponential height for
yeah right
okay so i'm gonna go and enable
volumetric fog so we might get some like
nice rays coming down
bump up my fog density
i'm going to reduce my fog max opacity
so we might get some of the clouds still
in the sky like
i found that it's useful to have a
cut-off point so you can still see the
sky if you have fog's max opacity that
one
might shroud out too much of the sky
it's like a harsh line for me zero
is completely off but 0.01 is completely
on
interesting
i i also just realized um
you know with if you have distance field
shadows enabled right up to the camera
you won't be able to see any volumetric
braids so i'm going to re-enable my
cascade
just
shadows
this
i think the main parameter to look at is
your extension for your volume volume
metrics like once you start bumping that
up you really start seeing like some ray
effects and
all sorts of things
extinction scale
yeah and then also scattering
distribution if you want like a really
dramatic like
strong sun it's really good to bump up
that scattering distribution
and i'm going to go for like a red
sunset look so from the
the youtube video that i was referencing
like some nice
nice red sunrise light um
see what i can do
your scene's looking really good man
like that just shows like you don't need
a huge landscape to like make something
impressive
yeah i think i i just need
so much more time spent with this
in order for it to even even for me man
like i i sort of know everything it's on
my fingertips but then
i just just diving in i realized like
all this stuff all these details i would
normally tweet if i had like
hours to spend
and apologies to the chat like i've
really been meaning to like interact
with the chat a bit more like
you guys are all taking your time
hanging out
but like
250 people showing you that
yeah we're all chilling
though yeah great stuff
we work with it we work with it
why not use rtvs not too sure what you
mean
what are rtvs
i
are vts sorry i'm not sure i'm not sure
what that is real
volume
someone said why are people choosing
unreal at the blender
um
i guess like
big environments i suppose i i guess i
talked about a bit about that before
to me they go
together they're perfect
absolutely i use blender i use blender
for all of my custom made uh 3d models
yeah i always go for blender
yeah like
they certainly go together
this is where you put put the pieces
together you know and this is where you
do it in real time
oh yeah one someone bring up brought up
a good point with um pixel depth um
personal and virtual texturing virtual
texturing i
don't personally use i've experimented
with it a little bit um
and it's a great way to get like your
assets blending with your landscape if
you want like a snow texture to come up
the roots of your trees and things like
that
but um but i found that you know there
are other alternatives like like you
mentioned pixel depth um if you include
a pixel depth offset
um
with your landscape material i suppose i
was trying to like demonstrate that
properly before but with a pixel depth
offset it references you can reference a
height map and then
when you merge assets with the landscape
it essentially blends them according to
the height map and it's super great
um
try and get quick
also i i hate this snow tiling as well
like i definitely notice it um that's
sort of what i put my macro variation in
my material for like about to bump up my
macro intensity yeah and get the scaling
right that gives enough variation but it
sort of gets rid of the um
a little bit that makes sense
if you have like right now i've got like
a really subtle like
reasonably subtle macro effect on the
snow
it like helps so much with tiling like
hmm i see what you're doing okay so it's
like it just it's adding
noise to the scene to make it
yeah kind of i um
i also have like my textures way too
small which is a problem
so maybe i can demo some of the um
maybe
i think the pixel depth is strong enough
like i think the material i've chosen
can actually have much depth to it like
it's fairly flat material
if i zoom all the way in
you can see it um
essentially references the height map to
blend smoothly i guess it kind of looks
smooth like the difference here between
the mesh and the ground
um that's something i like to focus on
with my scenes like when you get like
two
pieces of geometry that just like
fit together and then there's like a
really distinct line between them it can
be super jarring so
um pixel depth offset is a great way to
just like vary up the the transition
between meshes um okay
pixel depth offset that's what i need to
look into okay cool
it's good to reference a height map
texture for that it makes like some
really convincing effects but if not um
you can also
just plug in like a scalar parameter
maybe like multiply that by a
temporal a dita to get like a really
smooth
transition and then that's essentially
like a fade you can have like your your
asset like opacity fade out into the
landscape so it's like a really smooth
gradient
sweet but yeah that's that's
105 has so many amazing features uh
someone said in the chat well
i i would say unreal engine 5 is 98
on real engine 4. like you've got some
some nice features just to fit on the
top and then
but the bulk of it is still what unreal
engine 4 is actually so you've got like
all the same stuff
to me it's like
it's just cool how it automatically
sets up the lighting in the bounce light
and everything for you and it just looks
so beautiful i'm i've really been as a
beginner i've really been enjoying it
and like
getting a pretty immediate
uh
image that looks nice
makes me like more excited to to
continue to like create in the program
you know
yeah absolutely
you're talking about like unreal engine
five but yeah like
yeah booming and stuff yeah
yeah that technology is so impressive
i'm not sure if i'll be able to use it
for the the game i'm producing bots
um
now what you're doing now is beautiful
like your workflow is absolutely
incredible
i was going to say like i'd love to use
like lumen and stuff but it's actually
not particularly designed for masked
materials like
my landscapes are filled with plants
right and for plants you have to use
mass materials
um and there's not a whole lot of
support for that at the moment like if
you look at the stuff unreal engine is
doing with 105 it's all like
opaque message
opaque meshes you've got like the desert
uh environment which looks stunning but
yeah all opaque meshes
and this latest matrix
awakens uh thing they put together is
again all opaque messenger meshes for
all the buildings
um so
yeah i'm wondering like will will
natural
environments be it like sort of a
standstill with android g5 i'm not too
sure but
um but it's interesting if i maybe i'll
still be able to use my old tricks and
and get by but
i'd rather know them than not you know
yeah i mean i
i try really hard to just like
it's important with any software to like
you know spend the time learning new
features because
um it's always easy to like stay in your
stay in your comfort zone and stick with
what you know hence i haven't really
picked up any other renderers aside from
unreal
it's sort of part of my laziness but
yeah
it's all good
yeah hard to switch to a new program
that's why i've had such a difficult
time here is like trying to figure out
how to switch to a new program and like
there's so many roadblocks there's
there's so many hurdles to jump over but
you know
for me i have to find
the wins the small wins along the way
and like
forcing myself to complete a project
was a huge win for me like that music
video i did was a huge win and
that pushed me further to like continue
learning this program if if you don't
have small little wins for yourself it
makes it really hard to
to find the motivation to keep going
yeah absolutely
let's see
i think i'm i think i might be
somewhere
i'm gonna have maybe like a horribly
unoptimized package at the end of this
but
something
don't forget the obnoxious requirements
someone said
uh yeah i mean
you know on religion 4 when that came
out
the requirements were pretty obnoxious
back then as well like i i was trying to
run unreal when i started i had like a
um amd like really cheap card i was
getting like
30 frames a second
um
you know that stuff that stuff changes
with time like assume the standard will
be like
the rate these cards are getting
developed like the standard is going to
be like exponential the cards are going
to be like insane
it's just that's my prediction i guess
yeah it's just gonna it's gonna keep
getting better and better and more
accessible
that's a that's a
guarantee yeah i mean unreal like they
they really push accessibility like with
all their features like everything is
just like you know dragging into the
scene and it works like
um especially with like nanite all of
that virtualized geometry stuff like you
don't have to worry about poly counts as
much
super cool and like
in the future you you'll only have to
have like a base knowledge
all right i'm gonna i'm like
getting something ready here i'm just
gonna go into like some color correction
it doesn't look like we have too much
time
yeah
i was meaning to mention i guess i'll
mention it quickly for those listening
like there are some great features with
lighting that i use like
this installed ambient occlusion if
you've got distance field enabled for
your shadows or for some other reason um
ambient inclusion is a great like
like looks so great if i enable it real
quick
oh it's already enabled yeah it's like a
oh well
it just like makes these like nice
ambient occlusion spots where
it seems like it would naturally fit
it's super handy um
yeah that and um
you've got other tricks like you know
screen space ambient occlusion and
uh
i
i used to use these um these decals for
my from miami occlusion when i wanted
like some really big spots i'll just
one of my tricks actually close my heart
like you might get it
decal material and i put that into
my decal and then i put that in the dark
spot
also you're hand placing these like
ambient occlusion decals
yeah yeah it's like a hand placed thing
like it's if you want like in specific
areas there to be
[Music]
much more
variation so at the moment
can i notice that yeah you can sort of
see like there's a darkness patch
wherever i drag this decal yeah i just
enabled this field ammunition to show
this off but yeah
um
yeah it's smart because it doesn't
affect skylight like that's because it's
an ambient occlusion decal that only
affects shadows um
and i expect this is what they use like
when i look at some games like gta for
example you've got these cars with like
nice ambient occlusion underneath the
car it's because
they've attached an ambient occlusion
decal to the bottom i think that's why
because when you get the sun coming in
under the car there's no shadow
but then as soon as it's covered in
shadow again it's like you can see the
the influence of the ambient occlusion
it's pretty cool it's a pretty smart
thing it's just crazy that like all of
your
your games
are so
handmade
like
down to placing the shadows that's
insane that's so cool
yeah i guess i guess i i used to do the
same thing um it's just quickly i
mentioned with lights as well if you pop
in like a point light
uh and then just turn off shadows um
turn off
details uh then you can get like a
convincing like bounce light effect but
some
some areas obviously this takes a bit of
experimentation but
wow
um but it can be pretty cheap as well
and if it comes up in the fog
your specular
scale to zero
work
that totally makes sense though like
you set it to more of like a a warm kind
of light and it'll bounce right off
that's so good exactly
wow it's all these
lights that's great but also keeping in
mind like screen space global
illumination which is useful as well it
has like a fake uh
fake gi effects
um yeah it's just like it's a shame it's
like just about like the end of the
stream and i'm just like remembering
about all these tricks but
it's all good it's like as long as
people can like if you give them the
stuff that they can like go off so
screen space global illumination right
that's what that's another thing
uh yes yeah i mean that's uh
yeah that's a pretty effective one i
think you have to choose between screen
space
uh ambient occlusion and global
illumination you can't have both enabled
at once
yeah i guess this is just like leaving
little easter eggs for those that like
watch the whole the whole stream or the
whole board they'll be able to find the
real
[Laughter]
matt how do you work with big sorry i'm
just reading chat matt how do you work
with big maps without the engine lagging
um i'm getting a bit of lag at the
moment but
you just got to like
uh adjust one thing is adjust your
landscape leds
it doesn't have a huge influence but
it's helpful and another one is
yeah just like optimization in general
like keep your poly count slow keep your
lods like reasonably aggressive
um
that cold distances we have the objects
that you can't see in the distance so it
like calls them out of your
out of your vision uh yeah there's all
sorts of stuff that can
relate to that
so how are we looking what are there any
other things that you would need to do
to to bake this out as a as an exe or
you think we can
we can export this thing
the tips for that are essentially
file package windows and then you just
wait and then it takes a while to like
compile all the shaders um
which it takes longer the first time
than subsequent times but
um i think yeah after the stream i'll
just like hit that compile button see
where it gets i mean if i um
i
i go to my first person character which
i don't know where
yeah that look and then just do you want
to go full screen i'll go full screen on
you and you go full screen and
unreal and go your first person and just
kind of like walk around and then that's
kind of what
people will be able to see
when they download the exe there should
be a link here in the description
by the time you're watching this
hopefully
in the next
next hour or so
but you you it's 4am so
for you so
honestly i'm feeling i'm feeling fine
like i
yeah i've been i've been building up
this a little bit i had my coffee
you know i've been coughing all streams
um but yeah so i at the moment i i just
put in my first person template and
essentially gives me like you know wasd
controls i can walk around um
i have a camera i can bring that up i
can zoom in on stuff take some photos i
might zoom in on a tree just see what
we're working with
focus in
i've got some nice details
it's so cool um
actually it's cool because this template
also has a bunch of optimizations that i
put in my all my game settings so if i
like put my quality all the way down
um you might be able to get some of our
frames back somewhat
thank you
all right i'm just going to get stuck
into my um like do we do we have a
specific like limit on the stream like
do you reckon i'm happy to work just a
little bit longer to get to get
something that looks really good i can i
can so here's what i need to do
i need to move my car real quick that's
to take 30 seconds um i need to
come in come back here and
announce the winners of the weekly
challenge i can do that
while you work that might take 15
minutes or 20 minutes
i'll go through some honorable mentions
and then
to wrap the stream up we'll come back
and see what
see what your scene looks like and then
uh
and then we can call it
that sounds good to me i'd be happy to
look at
weekly winners as well though i was i
was excited to see like what people have
done cool yeah let me um
let me
run
to move my car real quick i'm gonna are
you good to be i'll just leave you here
with the audience doing your thing oh
yeah i'll be back in like a minute and a
half
and then we'll get into those weekly
winners good times see you in a second
sounds good sounds good
all right cayenne he said he was from
west australia it's at almost 4 a.m here
yeah that's that's where i am as well
it's 3 30.
i think we got the same time zone
what's in the decal um
i'll just check quickly
simple i made it a while ago it is
um you've got like a radial gradient so
if you plug in a density into the radial
gradient
um it just
effectively has
a circular drop off for the ambient
occlusion
i found that was a good way instead of
having any half edges like harsh edges
on the edge of the decal
um
yeah it just gets like a nice
sort of like a paint brush type thing
you can place around and i've just got
like a strength
did a bit of math and then
it's like super simple
i'm tempted to just like go full focus
mode but i feel bad
ignoring the chat so i'm just gonna
check in every once in a while
making a game kind of yeah i'm making a
scene which i can use as a game if i'd
like to
um obviously not everything is in
very good shape at the moment and we
don't have we're not optimized terribly
well but um
yeah the goal is to to prop this first
person template in and then export an
exe file and then people will be able to
download it and just walk around
uh yeah it's absolutely cool
i use assets i'll make it myself uh
almost almost completely i almost
completely source my assets so
there's a whole bunch of stuff available
like mega scans uh the unreal
marketplace i just
like download inbulk my library is huge
i just got back from trekking
surprised to see it that's crazy
i i would love to do that trick i saw
that video and yeah it's on my bucket
list for sure
looks stunning looks sonic never been to
nepal
and sorry i'm not really focusing i'm
just gonna
do
that's awesome too
awesome to be here man i'm so i'm so
it's so cool to like interact with you
guys
uh what gpu i've only got a um
i've got a mobile 2060 so i'm running
this off a laptop right now
um
and it's sort of sort of all i've got to
work with at the moment but
uh with the stuff i'm doing like you
know i can push decent frames like i'm
not i don't have too many issues
the reason why my shadows turn like
super black and i'm really confused
are you saying
oblivion
i've not played oblivion but
yeah i guess this reminds me of skyrim
in a way so
there you go
oh man it's super hard to work at the
same time maybe i'll just like read the
chat
yo
yo here we go
how you looking
looking good i
i am i've run into a problem with my
shadow
i might just give my project a quick a
quick restart
so
yeah just to see if that fixes
the problems with the shadows
[Music]
um i'm just uh hanging out with the chat
having a good time
sweet
i'm gonna i think it's time to review
some
some weekly art
how does that sound
yeah for sure that sounds great
sweet okay
so uh
every single week
on the discord the link is in the
description um
we do a weekly challenge and the prompt
this week was upside down
so i'm gonna review the upside down
winners reveal the five winners uh they
if you win you unlock the entire discord
server
it's a full server full of a bunch of
artists who are you know trying to help
each other out and share their work and
get advice and give advice
it's a nice place to
um
to go for that kind of stuff and
outside of the five winners we're gonna
talk about the honorable mentions as
well so
let's uh let's let's jump into it here
all right
so like i mentioned upside down is the
prompt for this week
so the first winner of the weekly
challenge this week is soulnate
with this super cool time magazine cover
um
definitely reminds me of the spiderman
uh the spider-verse like scene where he
drops down into the city it's like the
same body position but i just love the
way that you took that and you moved it
to a different kind of setup
i think this is really really cool i
don't know how you're gonna get
that little biplane
that little cessna in space but hey you
know you pulled it off it's freaking
sweet um
matt can you see this art by the way
yeah i was just figuring out i just had
to open the stream on discord but yeah
that's good now
yeah man
it's pretty sweet yeah it looks iconic
looks like a
yeah i could use that as a color for
sure
i feel like the only thing i would say
is like you're cut i just realized too
you're cutting off
time you're cutting off the bottom text
and i would maybe i would
i'm cool with that i love how the
plane's upside down
yeah yeah exactly that's like that's the
whole point right the prompt was upside
down so they're doing it in a pretty
sweet way
soulmate's a great artist
puts out really cool stuff
um next up sotomante working behind the
scenes do you mind just hiding the art
for me while i uh
bring up the next stuff thank you so
much sir
next up we have one dead duck with this
pretty pretty brutal scene here um
it'd be a be a rough scene to
to come across especially in one of your
games
matt that'd be uh
quite the site do you put easter eggs in
your games by by chance like do you slip
stuff in
i have done some stuff but like nothing
in the vein of like horror or anything
horrifying like i want to i want to
build trust with
people playing my games i'm not going to
chuck in like a like a jump scare
anymore
no that'd be rough you've asked me about
it yeah people ask me about it but no
i'm like straying away from that stuff
yeah that's good that's good what about
sentimental items do you put sentimental
items like
you sneak those around your uh your
scenes
oh yeah that's um that's one of the
mechanics like there are a bunch of
collectibles around and the object
changes depending on
which environment it is yeah that's cool
heck yeah
um
oh yeah this
i love like the
atmospherics like
you can never hate like having like a
good foggy background i love like the
color correction done on it as well yes
absolutely one dead duck puts out solid
work um wins these weekly challenges
quite often and i believe
uh this is made in unreal engine i think
unreal five i'm pretty sure he just
started getting into it so
he's doing a really really nice job
um
so congrats one dead duck you get the
challenge winner roll
this week
who do we got next
coming up
in
uh number three so i'm going to watch
you just hide it right off the bat
because they're going to double stack
here but number three we got
jc
kb with this beautiful
beautiful scene
um
i'm a huge fan of
the last of us and there's a scene in
the last of us too
where you go on this village and it's
lit like this it looks like this but you
added this like ufo
in here as well like it's so well done
it's so well lit i love your colors and
everything
that's awesome
yeah sorry i can only see like a small
version of it but
um yeah like those those reds and blues
i always love like those
that color scheme no matter what yeah
yeah it
looks great i love that lighting so much
such a big fan of that style so jc kb
congratulations you got the challenge
winner roll this week keep it up i think
this might be your second or third win
so congratulations to you
up next
uh in no specific order all right but
this is the fourth one here jack the
hack
i love this so much it feels like a
wolfenstein game or something uh but you
got this character
running on this on the top of this
mental asylum
i i assume is a mental patient it looks
like some crazy testing going on or
something or like
it's all jacked up i wonder where they
got that sword from that's a pretty cool
looking sword i just have so many
questions about this scene
but i love your color i love your
composition
i love the framing and the atmospherics
you have in this i think it's super cool
so
congratulations jack super nice super
nice work it reminds me of um i used to
play a bunch of battlefield one and
those like this look like one
like outfits
it's really hard to tell
but
it's like he's got that trench coat vibe
to it and the guns like i don't they
look like sticks almost
i don't know some experts probably
waiting ready to like own us on that but
it's the boots and the long coats
but yeah they actually don't look like
guns
from this view maybe they are though
but anyway
jack the hack congratulations very good
stuff
and finally
we have
our very own
visual
killing it
with this
like dude your render quality is insane
this is basically yeah that is not yeah
that's like a picture it's like a really
well-lit
uh
picture that's insane how good this is
your character work and your render
quality
is off the charts man um
absolutely
put that in the genre of like zoom like
look really closely and squint to see if
you can tell if it's a render or not
that's the
character yes
exactly that's what i strive for with
all my renders
and you are killing it right now visual
so congratulations
since you're already you're a moderator
right mods can win this thing it just
comes down to the art you got the good
art are you gonna win this or not um
but
since you already have full unlock of
the server you got your challenge winner
role ready to be passed off to
one of our honorable mentions and i
don't know if he's first up but i will
definitely get there
uh when it comes along so sotomante
working behind the scenes right now if
you could just uh work from the top down
on honorable mentions and just tell me
who it is and all
i'll get into it
all right we got lil child support
uh as the first honorable mention
i dig this so much like i love your
silhouette i love your colors and i love
your framing and i think this just looks
awesome so you should
please keep it up i've seen you on the
server doing some awesome stuff keep
doing your thing this looks fantastic
yeah your colors and your silhouettes
are great i love working with
silhouettes it's the best
so good um
honorable mention number two
we got
dre
g
up next i believe
yeah this is awesome i love your colors
here
i love your composition your framing
is super solid
um
you came very close you came very close
to winning this one if i had to give any
advice or any like
any pointers maybe i don't know maybe
move some of the asteroids below
the astronaut as well
and maybe take the two out that are
behind his arm by his by his fingers and
his arm and move them down
below the actual astronaut
oh it's very like the harsh
the harsh space like coming in
like
with strong shadows looks good chris
yeah the space lighting is a really hard
vibe to nail and you did a really good
job here so
dre g congrats for that honorable
mention keep it up
doing good stuff
next up we have what do we got uh
triple 07
is next up for honorable mention i love
your composition i love this idea so
much it's such a cool idea
um your lighting even is fantastic like
this is super solid i feel like you can
probably get some crown molding up there
between the the wall and the ceiling
and i i'm having trouble deciding like
what that is on the window on the right
is that the moon is that
outside it's a little hard to tell but
overall i really dig this what do you
think matt
yeah it's like super super interesting i
personally like
i would have to wreck my brain to come
up with that kind of concept i think
that's really cool yeah it's super sick
really good stuff triple 07
keep it up
um next up we have pics win
for honorable mention you came darn
close
very similar vibe
i just
love your colors love your composition
and i love your lighting so i wanted to
give you a shout out
i thought this was super cool
keep up the good work
very good stuff
and
finally we have
the game factory for honorable mention
and visual is going to pass
his weekly challenge winner roll off to
you
you like yours the most
and this is just a cool little cool
little video here
at this point i'm like wait what
how do these two places like what is
going on
okay okay okay it's a little space set
up
and they have a very intricate diorama
that must have taken so long
that's awesome uh the game factory very
good stuff
i dig it congratulations to all the
challenge winners soul nate one dead
duck jc kb
uh
jack the hack and visual
y'all are doing great stuff you got the
challenge winner roll
and the game factory of course
very awesome
uh matt we're we're nearing the end here
we're at the end of this stream did you
want to sounds like it
do touch on any last little things
before we wrap it up
i mean
i'm not too sure i think um yeah i
wanted to mention that i'll
i'll be putting out an exe of this
project that i did um
even if yeah obviously the cracks are
there like i threw it together um
but yeah i'm excited for people to to
watch the vod and then maybe try it out
if you were to leave the link in the
description
i think that's a cool way like like
seeing seeing the seeing the software
downloading downloading it and like
exploring yourself um
it's like definitely definitely
heightens the experience like it
definitely changes everything
i'm super yeah i'm super excited for you
guys to try it out
you also uh like unlocked download of
your latest game right that's also in
the description yeah
um yeah i
i think i'll i think i'll leave that
enabled for quite a while so
i'll leave it up for like the next week
or so it's like a beta for the game that
i'm working on at the moment
which is
the entire game is a compilation of
environments that you're able to explore
and take photos in
but the beta is just one environment
it's an environment inspired by the
italian alps um
so if you have a pc rig that you can try
it out on you don't necessarily need a
high end graphics card i think um
1060 is like the minimum recommended
spec so
sweet um so yeah try it out let me know
your thoughts i have a discord and stuff
um yeah i'm just trying to build
something that hopefully everyone will
get behind um
yeah so yeah
man i really appreciate the the chance
to like
show off the stuff that i'm doing and
like what i'm working towards um
yeah honestly i'm super lucky i really
appreciate it dude absolutely and we're
gonna
be in touch and we're gonna keep hanging
out and learning together and i i can't
wait to learn more from you and i can't
wait to see this game when it finally
drops the full deal but like seriously
if you all want to
dive into
the max the maxed out version
of what we just did on the stream
click the link to cave's
website it's in the description below
go there scroll down a little bit you
can download the game
the beta for this certain level and hop
in and see it for yourself it's it's
unbelievable it's so cool
um so dude thank you so much for joining
me thanks for doing this together like
thanks for your patience
um
yeah have a freaking great holiday have
a take a break chill out and
enjoy yourself man you find it thanks
man
i yeah i had such a great time and like
having tons of people watching
interacting with people in the chat yeah
it's been so great
heck yeah i do um
sweet i hope you guys enjoy it yeah if
you guys would be winter at the moment
for us i'm
starting to heat up got some warm summer
days ahead um
that's so crazy
i don't prefer i don't prefer summer for
like doing doing work and working on
environments but
but you know maybe i'll have to take a
trip up to the northern hemisphere for a
bit
please do please come visit los angeles
all right i'd love to someday
yeah man we'll freaking do it we'll hang
out and we'll we'll go on a hike or
something we'll do something awesome oh
hell yeah oh yeah
all right man
good times
peace out thank you all for joining us
ggs everybody
later
[Music]
two
[Music]
you